And Morgan Masters are out there.
I use one out,
three,
two,
one boom.
And we're live.
We're just talking about target panic.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Shows people don't know about all this
lake.
Uh,
uh,
erectile dysfunction for entry.
It's panic.
Freak out it because you want that Arrow
to go so bad.
By the way.
Thanks for having me on my pleasure.
I understand from all the input I get
from all of my intelligent friends that
you deserve me,
Huh?
So I'm excited.
We'll have a good time with your,
your assistant reached out and said
people reach out.
She said,
I think you'll have more in common with
Ted.
Then you realize that was her.
That was her pitch.
Truth,
logic,
common sense.
Spirit,
physics of,
uh,
the American dream.
Perhaps controversial and misunderstood
people.
Oh yes.
Boy.
We're surrounded.
Oh,
maybe both of cluster.
Fuck ringing.
Any bells?
Yes,
indeed.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So target,
panic.
I got lucky in that a,
I got hooked up with John Dudley early
before I developed target.
Panic is the master and he explained to
me shot sequences.
Yeah.
Shot sequences.
And let's,
let's make this available
universally to all of our podcast
friends out there in life.
The clusterfuck to omniscience is what
we aspire to.
A maximum level of awareness on all
fronts.
Our curfew or a welder or a podcast or a
guitar player,
a butcher,
right?
Maximum efficiency.
I'm being the best that you can be,
clear mind,
clear conscience,
true north compass in the world of
archery because it does consume you.
And here I am,
70 years clean and sober because I'm
currently an forever consumed with the
mystical flight of the era,
which is the origins of Zen.
The Japanese religion of not shooting an
Arrow,
not being an arrow,
but being the path of your life.
And if you use the gifts from God to the
ultimate application of efficiency and
effectiveness,
you can put that fucking Arrow right,
right.
What you want it to,
and the baggage that all humans have to
deal with and it's most painfully
manifested in the pursuit of archery is
too many minds.
You can't think about it.
If you got to think about playing Wang
Dang sweet.
Poon Tang ain't going to play it.
It better just be you and unleash and
with an Arrow because you want to let
that Arrow go because you're.
You're shooting an arrow.
Archery,
I need to put that out down there in
that bullseye or on that pump station or
that crease of the Buffalo,
and so you want it to go because that's
what you're here for is to let the Arrow
go.
So you got to tell yourself,
you can't let the Arrow go.
You have to shoot so many arrows
throughout your life that no,
no.
Too many minds,
subconscious physics,
spirituality ingrained deep within your
origins and aboriginal ancestry.
There it is.
If ever there was an aim,
small Ms. Small perfection.
It's archery and let me,
I don't mean to monologue here.
Oh,
this is so much of my life.
I know.
No matter what you do,
and I've done this since the sixties
when the hippies were trying to get me
stone and I'm going,
no,
that's not what you want to do.
What you want to do is get a bone arrow.
Would you want to do is escape what
you're trying to escape,
the pressures,
fuck those pressures.
You be the source of pressure,
not the receiver of pressure,
and my dad raised me.
My Dad was a drill sergeant.
God blessed that son of a bitch is
awesome.
I hated them.
Discipline,
discipline,
especially at the archery range and so I
learned archery and when I'm playing
guitar and I'm playing all this
outrageous,
chuck berry,
Bo Diddley,
a little richard stuff and everybody's
getting high and drunk and they're
really great musicians and the more high
in the more drunk they got.
They became less great musicians until
the point where they weren't even
musicians anymore and so I would escape
that and I as 1112 and there was no
hippies.
It was beatniks and I'd get back to my
little house in Redford on the Rouge
River in Detroit and I get that little
bone Arrow and I go down to skunk hallow
and a river rat.
And even as a stupid mushy brained idiot
child,
I was able to
little the Longbow.
No recurves yet.
And you know,
I could shoot a rat in the eye because I
had no baggage yet.
I haven't developed any social baggage
and that has served me.
So the many minds,
many.
I know.
Mine's the baggage.
Yeah.
Too many miles.
I think that that's a thing that people
don't shoot arrows when you start
talking about this,
they don't really understand what you're
saying.
I know exactly what you're saying.
But for a lot of people,
this is a very misunderstood subject,
right?
Yep.
That did that,
that this is a meditation.
There's a meditation involved in the
absolute meditation.
You,
it's out of body.
The ultimate Arrow,
like the ultimate guitar lick,
I suspect a comedian on stage,
which I qualify it.
You can't be thinking of your routine.
It's got a flow.
I mean,
I was in the presence of Sam Kinison for
50,
60 spontaneous performances and Robin
Williams at the comedy store.
And,
and,
uh,
Richard Pryor,
you see,
remember I mentioned a moment ago,
I've been on the mountain top with Bill
Strop and the Broncos and Parnelli Jones
taught me to raise.
I played bass for Chuck Berry.
And Bo Diddley,
I mean I'm married,
Mrs Nugent.
I mean I've been to the peak of peaks
available to mankind.
I hunted with Fred fucking bear.
When did you do that?
I have five or six.
I met him.
He was started the brand new archery
shopping,
grayling,
Michigan.
My Dad was already a follower before I
was exploring to people who he is,
people who are uninitiated.
Powerful story.
He's like the Richard Pryor of archery.
I was expecting his afro to catch fire
any moment.
So I'm already into bows and arrows.
I don't know who fred bear was.
I really was just getting baptized by
the Chuck Berry,
Bo Diddley,
electronic guitar or g,
and in that late forties,
early fifties.
It was a firestorm of defiance and
rebellion musically manifested,
but Roy,
whether b was going beyond the 30 slash
30,
which everybody used for deer hunting
and it was a good hundred yard and for
real marchmen real zen marksman could
shoot a 30,
3,200 plus yards whether open sites or
scope and marksmanship and sniper
discipline was a powerful force in a
hunting family and in all families.
Every family I knew,
we all shot every weekend,
pistols,
shotguns,
rifles,
20 twos,
hunting,
woodchucks and Freiberg,
Pennsylvania with the target master
Remington single shot bolt,
20 to 22 shorts,
twenty five cents a box at the dry goods
store.
It's awesome.
And with my dad taught me to shoot him
in the eye.
Aim Small Miss Small breathe site
acquisition.
You have a responsibility to kill that
animal outright if you're going to
utilize that precious gift of flesh and
for body fluids and bone,
you better kill him clean because you're
a reasoning predator.
You have a moral,
intellectual and spiritual obligation to
kill your dinner humanely and cleanly.
Duh.
And so that marksmanship routine was
developing with ballistic Ted nugent,
ballistically maximized firepower.
And Roy stands for,
I thought it said bad motherfucker,
you know,
that has a ring to it.
Maybe that's maybe that's what it good.
Alright.
So Fred Threadbare,
Fred Beck.
So Roy,
whether be was extending long range
marksmanship and developing the,
the famous,
whether it be magnums with more powder,
more efficient burning powder.
I'm better primers,
better designed ballistic bullets that
would cut air better and go flatter,
longer,
better trajectory and velocity,
and so it was fun to shoot that deer or
a bullseye at 100 yards.
That takes a lot of trigger control and
discipline,
but now roy,
whether it be was creating,
whether it be magnums,
the 300,
whether it be magnum shout,
100,
eight years,
80 grain,
bullet it 32,
3,400 feet a second,
which was unheard of,
and so you could aim small,
Ms. Small,
and if you really got that really
intricate,
meticulous,
triggered a smoothness,
you could shoot thousand yards once you
learn the trajectory of your gun.
However,
1911,
the last of the Yani Indians issue was
discovered in Oroville.
I can't believe I remember all this in
Oroville,
California,
northern California,
and there was a bounty on Indians back
then.
You could shoot a man Indian and get 25
bucks.
You shoot until 11.
Yep.
They had bounties on him instead of
shooting this,
Yani,
this last Indian,
they called the local sheriff and they
took him into custody and they called,
uh,
some scientists.
And uh,
pellant theologists,
I'm from California University by the
name of our Saxton Pope,
and Saxton pope came and studied egg as
a,
as a aboriginal last pope,
Pope and young that's right.
And then he contacted his buddy,
art young,
who also studied in that genre and they
discovered ecg and they were fascinated
by his stealthy awareness of the
wilderness in his archery control,
with his funny little style of shooting
the bull with his thumb and getting
close and doing an ice cold river
bathing before the hunt to cleanse
himself to be worthy of the beast.
So Fred bear witnessed the film that
Pope and young eventually made of them
becoming consumed with the mystical
flight of the Arrow.
Now this was in the twenties and
thirties,
and they put a newsreel out when all
over the country and showed this
newsreel of hunting with the bone Arrow
by Saxton Pope in art,
young shooting grizzly bears in Yosemite
and going to Africa,
filling lines full of arrows.
They weren't really as good as he.
She said they'd fling arrows.
And these animals pretty relaxed,
almost tame because they'd never been
hunted like that before.
And so fred bear come from Pennsylvania
around that time to work at the palm oil
company,
building cabinets for the new radio.
They just invented in the wood
dashboards for the Ford Motor Company.
And he was also making bows a handmade.
You wouldn't,
or osage orange bows in his little
archery shop with nels grumbly.
I can't believe I remembered Nell's
grumbling one of the greatest boyers of
all time.
So my dad got the archery bug because
Fred defied the trend of easier hunting,
easier,
long range.
You didn't have to be very stealthy
issue to dear 500 yards.
They don't even know you're there.
I have to do is be a discipline
Marchmen,
which is a discipline and a great
accomplishment unto itself.
And it was a new challenge for long
range ballistic capability.
Will Pope and young and a handful,
fred bear knows grumbly went and saw
this newsreel of these guys,
these doctors,
these,
uh,
professors hunting all over the world
with these handmade bows and fed was
already into it.
And he was,
I'll be damn this,
I didn't realize you could do that.
And so now people after seeing the pope
and young newsreel started asking Fred
to make bows and it's spread.
So we started the bear archery company,
late twenties,
early thirties,
and he moved to grayling up in the
northern part of Michigan with a
wilderness was,
and they had cut down all the trees.
So there was this new growth of ideal
wildlife habitat because not many
animals can live in an old growth forest
and our tool,
but you need low level escape sanctuary
and browse that the animals can access.
And so fred was now promoting our tree
and Michigan won all the,
uh,
national field archery championship
championships along with an Marston.
It's awesome.
And so my dad was a follower because
he'd come back from World War II and he
needed that escape.
He needed that cleansing to get away
from that horror,
which is why they never talked about it.
And so we go up north every year,
October first,
the new gene family and the Ford station
wagon.
And I had my little bone Arrow with the
suction cups,
and I'd shoot stuffed animals off the
couch,
but my dad would walk the woods with his
real bowl and we'd stop at this little,
a brick shack that said bear archery.
And I had no idea.
And so I was already into bows and
arrows shooting all the time.
I was obsessed.
I was under the river every day.
No baseball,
no football,
no hockey bows and arrows,
bows,
murals,
critters.
I think I had the songbird world slammed
by the time I was eight.
And,
uh,
and so now I'm meeting this tall,
lanky gentleman named Fred Bear.
It didn't register with me until I
started seeing him on the cover of true
magazine and sporting magazines and in
life magazine with a Grizzly bear and an
elephant and a tiger and a lion in the
newsreels.
And I'm going,
I'm shooting river rats,
which is so thrilling.
I can't even describe it.
And here's this long,
lanky,
tall,
lanky guy that was building bows in this
rustic,
rustic shop in northern Michigan.
On my way to my favorite thing in life,
October,
first opening day of archery season as a
six,
seven,
eight year old boy and we'd have
chocolate milk and Cherry Pie with this
fred bear guy.
Now it's registering.
This is the Chuck Berry of bonding.
This is it.
This is the guy.
So I became a namerd with him and he was
kind to me and he'd show me stuff,
but I got to hang out with them as I
grew.
By the time I was 16,
we moved to Chicago was my dad got
transferred,
but I got to visit with Fred bear at
least every other October.
Never hunted with them and I'm now.
I started amboy,
dukes.
I'd already had a great band when the
battle of the bands in Michigan with the
lawyers.
We opened up for the supreme and the
Bulb Romas at Cobo Hall.
Wow.
And so now I'm in Chicago shooting my
boner all the time.
Started the amboy dukes playing like a
madman,
graduated in 67,
went back to Michigan that two years
later and immediately went up to
grading.
We're now,
there's this huge cathedral bear archery
and fred bear is like that dude is like
the sporting dude because he taught the
long range marksman that there's an
intimacy,
there's a a better learning process and
more lesson to not kill the animal,
but to understand your relationship with
the animal and to try to use those God
given gifts.
I mentioned a moment ago to penetrate
the otherwise impenetrable defense
system of game because they are sneaky,
elusive crafty.
God made them to get away from guitar
players with sharp sticks and so this
caught on because people go,
you know,
I killed my deer every year with my 30,
30 now with the 30 odd six and Roy Beth
rather be long range.
I wonder if I'm a bad ass enough to get
close to a deer with a bow and arrow.
So it caught on like wildfire and they
made the first.
Fred got the first legal season in
Michigan,
the Alagan state park on November first
19,
47.
George Nichols,
my buddy got the first legal buck and
Michigan with a bone Arrow on that
morning,
and so I knew these are the guys I hang
with.
These were the founders.
These were like you were.
I was at the concord bridge of our tree
and so fred had embraced me.
It was real suspicious of the long
haired Hippie looking,
you know,
rock and Maniac Motor City Madman,
but all of his friends would not.
No,
he's not into drugs.
He's in fact,
he's anti-drug and he's always promoting
our trash out my bone,
Arizona state forever,
like shoot flaming arrows at skulls and
a big illegal.
I think it was a felony,
a big Turkey vulture I stuff,
but it looked great.
Backlit,
you know,
and I'd shoot that fucker off this amps
at night.
People didn't know whether to shit or go
blind is this wild man screen,
the bird lands,
make it all this outrageous racket.
I come up with a bow and Arrow and a
flaming Arrow and blow up a Turkey
vulture.
What more do you want?
And so fred got looked past the insanity
of the fear factor of rock and roll,
and he finally admitted to me,
he said,
sporting good show.
I go to Ted.
All the young people,
anybody under 30,
all they want to know is if I know Ted
nugent,
because that was the first time they
ever saw bone arrow.
And they read my you my interviews about
the the spirit,
the cleansing of escaping,
the insanity of whatever your job
description might be.
Mine being maniacal rock and roll.
I need to shut the fuck up,
take a deep breath,
get my bone Arrow,
let my guitars breed head back to the
woods
and live and remember who I am and what
I'm here for.
And I never killed a deer as little too
uppity and we didn't know what we were
doing back then.
You were too uppity,
you think?
What do you mean?
I just,
I'm high energy.
So you had to
be too loud.
I mean,
I could walk through.
I learned from Fred Ed.
I learned
to walk toe first and I learned to go
anything you
instead of stepping over and to stay in
the shadows so I knew the maneuvers,
but coming out of a tour and playing 350
nights a year and then you get a couple
of days after in November and you get
that bone marrow.
It's hard to go from that to total
silence,
but you know what?
I've mastered it.
I know yet.
Finally.
I mean I did,
but then you might take a long time by
the sixties.
I don't know about masters.
You'll never master it,
but I've mastered transition.
What do you say when people.
Like.
One of the arguments about hunting that
people bring up is why would you use a
bow and arrow bone is not as effective
if you wanted to kill somebody issues at
gun.
There's people that don't hunt that
think that hunting should only be one
thing and it should only be killing the
animal from me.
Whereas I think that someone who hunts
definitely kills the animal from me.
There's more.
There's more to the whole thing.
Have you ever seen me expound on that
fun sport meet trophy.
You can't hunt without having fun or you
won't do it.
It's fun to challenge yourself.
It's fun to get up and some people will
have a problem with that word.
They can kiss my ass if it wasn't fun.
None of us would do it.
I understand your,
your your take on it.
They can kicks kiss your ass,
but you.
It means something to you.
It's not as simple as like,
fuck you.
This is just how I'm going to do it.
Deep Fun is being the greatest
basketball.
Three point shooter.
Isn't that fun?
Must be discipline.
He will,
but it's.
It's always fun.
It's because it's invigorating and the
bow hunting is more invigorated because
it's so difficult.
Borderline impossible,
fun sport it.
Why?
I don't think sport hunting is good.
You shouldn't have sport.
How can you hunt without sport,
but don't you think that there's just
too many of these words are poisoned.
There's like trophy hunting.
Can't hunt without a trophy.
You know what I have on my wall in my
northern cabin?
You're going to.
You already are inclined to love me,
but now you're really going to.
You're going to fuck me right here on
the show.
That's not loved.
Well,
it's a metaphorically speaking is for
some of my buddies.
Anyhow,
so on the wall of my cabin in northern
Michigan is my first kill.
November 15th,
19,
69.
My Dad's priest.
Sixty seven months.
Fuck button.
Buck.
Do you hear the story?
Yeah,
and I took it to the taxidermist and I
said I want this mind what he said here
to mount this,
but button button.
Buck is a font of the year,
but it has little buttons on his
forehead which is illegal deer with a
doe tag.
And I had that year and I said,
it's a buck feel.
You have to feel on the to make sure it
is a buck is it's such a little guy and
it's illegal dear,
and it's a delicious deer.
The deer,
the year is a fond.
That's why we have this hunting season
in the fall because now they're
independent.
They're not there had been weaned.
They're,
they're independent animals.
In fact,
the,
the button bucks are there assets get
kicked by their mother to throw him out
of the herd and get the hell out of the
way for more breeding,
which is what I do.
And uh,
and so I have that button,
buck mounted.
Well,
who's going to tell me that's not a
trophy?
The,
the,
the experiences,
the memories,
the clothes,
the bullets,
the day,
the sunrise,
the crows,
the sandhill cranes,
the birds,
the movement,
the anticipation.
And I got backstraps.
I had fun.
Ultimate discipline,
challenge,
sport,
ultimate meet,
ultimate protein.
The purest,
most organic before it was even hip.
And if you could I dare you to tell me
that button.
Buck is not a trophy.
I got,
I have woodchucks mounted.
I got a shot.
I would chuck in the eye with my
grandson when I have,
I have squirrels.
Mount.
He's always a trophy mounts.
Squirrels.
The squirrels are,
um,
you know,
when you,
when you first start out and you killed
that first squirrel.
That's exciting stuff.
It's,
it's,
it's always put a squirrel that you're
mounted on a,
on a limb at the,
in the cabin along with Rocco and my son
out here is first one we'd duck that.
He got very,
uh,
with much effort and we have that would
duck mounted.
There's a,
there's a love affair with our
instinctual stewardship duties to the
wildlife to harvest the surplus,
to make room for next spring's
productivity because there's going to be
more animals,
but there's not going to be more
habitat.
Hence sustain yield successful wildlife
management model.
That is so perfect.
It defies criticism.
Unless your alliance sack of Shit.
Have you ever had to have a reasonable
conversation with someone who's anti
hunting?
Do you ever like sat down?
Yeah,
often.
Absolutely.
And to the man and woman,
I mean adamant Vegan until I explained
to them,
well vague and I like that Vegan,
a Vegan,
whatever is in Vegan.
I can't even pronounce it much less
really comes out of your mouth.
Figure it out.
So stupid.
My,
by the way,
my son Rocco,
who I love beyond description Vegan.
No.
Yes,
he has.
He needs to eat more
when he's asleep.
I try to shove up backstrap up his ass,
but he's got more muscles that I do.
Anyhow.
My point is,
is that how that.
How did he become Vegan?
He hasn't died yet.
He has a digest.
He has a great hunter.
He doesn't like to hunt anymore.
He's decided not to.
He's killed.
Great dear.
Great Hogs.
I've seen them on your TV.
Shit.
Ducks.
Yeah.
He's a great hunter,
but he does.
He decided he does not want to take part
in the harvest.
I respect it completely,
but if you.
If you really want to kill the most
things,
be a vegan because the farmers who
protect your beans kill everything.
I kill one animal per arrow.
In order to grow Tofu,
you have to kill every ground.
Squirrel,
every role,
every shoe,
every snake,
every turtle,
every frog,
every bird,
every rabbit,
anything that gets in that bean field,
I'm either going to plow and dismember,
which is
why the corrosion,
the seagulls follow the,
the combines.
It combines every year,
and then if anything does survive.
My first slaughter,
I'm going to come in with man's Santa
when poisoned the shit out of everything
so you can have a tofu salad and not be
responsible for any death.
Fuck you.
That's a really good point and it has to
have a lot of people ignore and avoid
because it's.
It's uncomfortable,
isn't life full of uncomfort and thing
and you shouldn't be uncomfortable to
kill.
Game to feed mankind is perfect to kill
cows and pigs to feed mankind.
It's the system is often less than
perfect,
but until someone comes up with a better
system,
I salute and genuflect at the altar of
farmers and ranchers and people who kill
animals to sustain my fellow man.
I agree with you.
I think you and I would probably both
disagree with factory farming when you
see animals stuffed into pitches,
but we have come up with a better
system.
I killed a lot of deer and I.
I feed more people than any.
Any hunter ever.
I killed so many much game of years.
I have to.
I have to hire sharp shooters.
I guy.
I killed the animals on my beautiful
swamp and Michigan and my Texas property
that have to die.
They have to get out of there to make
room for the next year's funds,
so I've soup kitchens,
homeless.
Yeah.
I literally give tons and I'm a
sweetheart,
but I'm not an idiot.
I keep the backstraps,
but I give tons of venison to soup
kitchens and homeless shelters and
veterans.
We make jerky and send it over to the
troops overseas.
I mean I have to adjust my halo or just
to get in the room.
So what I do is literally perfect.
Well the problem is what you do.
Everybody can do like everybody's not
going to have.
You're kind of warn people could though.
More people could.
Yes.
Well you would definitely.
I know the hunters for the hungry
distributed a ton of $250.
Two hundred $50 million Joe.
Two hundred and $50 million meals every
year.
A venison in.
There are people that would ban that.
Shame on you?
Well,
I do.
I just think there's a lot of films and
a lot of documentaries that portray
veganism is being this perfect way of
living that doesn't have any death or
any habitat loss associated with it,
and then they look at the extreme of
mediating,
which is the worst aspects of it.
Factory farming.
Some of these disgusting pig farms,
chicken,
disgusting,
horrible,
horrifying.
The upgrade goes on because more alarms
have been sounded not by paid and not by
the humane society of the United States.
They're just scam artist by people who
are coming to realize that we do not
only have a responsibility to kill
critters,
to feed mankind,
but it can be done in an environmentally
beneficial way.
I mean,
if you watch my great late friend
Anthony Bourdain on his shows and Andrew
Zimmern on the travel channel,
you watch their shows and the emphasis
on environmentally friendly
productivity.
More and more organic farming.
More and more conscientious waste
dispersal,
whether it's,
you know,
pig guts and a read we utilize.
Those are in Las Vegas.
They get all this wasted food and they
feed the pigs so it's good food going
in.
The port tastes better,
so there is upgrade taking place and
here's the ultimate inescapable fact of
upgrade environmentalist
environmentalism.
When I was grown up,
Joe Lake Erie would catch fire because
of the pollution.
It wasn't.
Environmentalist are greenies that
sounded the alarm.
It was the duck hunters that said,
you're polluting this area so bad.
There's no ducks.
There's no wild salary.
There's no wall eyes,
there's no fish,
there's no muskrats for the trappers.
Hunters,
fishermen and trappers have sounded the
alarm more often than not,
about environmental irresponsibility and
now lake Erie,
they would spontaneously combust when I
was growing up,
is now the number one walleye and small
mouth bass fishery in the world and it's
still,
we're still producing and still got the
industrial revolution going on there.
But conscientious,
higher responsible level of awareness is
spreading like wildfire across the
country.
And I believe that there's no mutual
exclusivity whatsoever to productivity
and environmental responsibility.
I believe that they both benefit each
other.
And I've got so many,
um,
unlimited examples where that worked
from farms.
It mean people who live downwind of a
pink pig farmers are going to be the
biggest squawker is rightly so.
Yeah.
And,
and so I see a lot of upgrade going on,
more organic,
more conscientious,
less waste.
It's not,
um,
it's not as a regular operating
procedures.
That should be.
But I see upgrade.
I see.
I think you're right.
And I think that the,
the thought process behind all these
people that are upset about factory
farming people even that go Vegan,
the thought process behind it is in the
right place.
I just think there's a lot of misguided
energy there because they don't really
understand where the food is coming
from.
They don't understand large scale
agriculture that understand when you.
And a lot of large scale agriculture is
to grow food to feed animals that
essential.
Yeah.
But it's also wheat and is also a lot of
grain that people consume and that
displaces thousands and thousands of
acres of animals.
And the process is not a clean process.
It's not clean in terms of there's no
death,
there's no harm,
it's cruelty free.
This crazy as if you can possibly go
through a day without having blood on
your hands.
Do you drive on the highways?
Does any of your sustenance come on the
highways?
Because billions of animals are
slaughtered on the highways every day
and if you are on planet earth,
part of that blood is on your hands.
You got to be.
Who doesn't know this?
He was,
not to admit this,
but again,
I see an upgrade in level of awareness
and responsibility,
but the charge began in the hunting,
fishing and trapping community because
where does,
where does quality,
air,
soil,
and water come from?
I'll go ahead and answer that wildlife
habitat out of the people that are out
there every day to recognize it in more
and more.
You know,
I used to,
I still get death threats because I am
murder innocent animals,
but now I get those too.
What the hell?
So it's just so absurd.
But I think their heart like right
place,
they just don't know what they're
talking about.
They're just haters.
They're just a bit of that.
In 2018,
do you not acknowledged barbecue?
How in 2018 do you not acknowledge
there's a few dead Turkeys on
Thanksgiving?
What do you mean you going to be brain
dead?
I think they're so consumed with hate
that they fight.
Ignorance is acceptable.
I'm a grownup.
When I go to the indy 500,
I couldn't turn a cogsworth.
I don't.
I'm ignorant about cogsworth.
Ignorance is acceptable because you can
remedy it with knowledge and research.
Stupidity is when you guard your
ignorance,
if you think that were murdering
innocent animals to feed our families
with the purest protein available to
mankind.
Balancing the herds with more deer,
more elk,
more bison,
more turkeys,
more waterfowl,
more cougars,
more bears than ever in recorded history
except for the bison,
but we're way back.
We have as many bisons we can sustain in
North America.
A lot of the native American tribes are
desperate to get more harvested in an
efficient and responsible manner.
So wildlife is thriving because hunters
implemented regulations for sustained
yield.
How many ducks can we kill?
How many will they reproduce?
Where's their habitat determines their
reproduction.
We must safeguard that Delta waterfowl,
ducks unlimited,
but see,
this information is universally
available,
but the fake news,
academia,
Hollywood,
and half of our government is stone
cold,
obsessed with political correctness and
denial.
Yeah,
so I do what I do and our spirit of the
wild showed been number one.
An outer challenges is 29 years now.
Wow.
I'm getting old because we say it like
it is.
We don't play around fun sport.
Meet trophy,
sacred beast.
Prayer for the wild things.
Resource Stewardship,
conservation wise,
use.
Walk the wild ground.
Before you comment on the wild,
grown the.
Well this is what I'm talking about when
you were talking about that last Indian,
but they found the guy who started river
study issue.
Okay.
I will write it down.
What's this?
How do you suppose I s h I.
You have to learn this.
I'm going to send you a bunch of stuff.
I'm going to get your contacts and I'm
going to send you stuff.
It will expand your horizons like you
didn't know was available.
The.
The history of modern bowhunting at the
hands of Fred.
Bear and and Saxton Pope and young and
the families that wanted to get closer
to game,
not necessarily kill because 90 percent
of the time you don't kill squat with a
bone Arrow,
but when you do,
it's because you dedicate yourself to a
higher reasoning level,
Predator awareness and you put your
gifts from God to the maximum efficiency
and again,
that's welding and carpentry,
but ultimately you're going to kill
some.
You better kill it,
clean and being human and failing
overall to be perfect.
You can be perfect and put that Arrow
when you learned.
Read the wild signals,
the,
the attitude,
and the the,
the bird indicators.
When the deals come in,
you use the light,
the wind,
the camel,
stealthy movements,
silence and learned time that shot.
My average deer dies in five seconds.
The the top of the heart taken off.
Both lungs are penetrated at deer falls,
asleep on his feet and there's never
been a beef steak ever had it.
So good.
The also,
there's a connection to what you're
doing that's different than almost any
other connection to food.
I mean,
the only thing that's reasonably close
and it's pretty far off is when you grow
it yourself,
so if you grow your own vegetables,
you get a connection to that food,
but absolutely it's not the same
connection as you get.
No,
because you're just going to send an
Arrow through an animal.
You look in his eyes,
you look in that size,
but also the,
you know how difficult it is and when
you pull it off,
there's this powerful connection between
you and that animal.
You earn and you earn burn and when you
eat it,
you feel that you earned it.
I'm telling you way out of it.
When Anthony Bourdain came to my place,
he was still a little squeamish with
killer stuff.
Even though he ate dead stuff on every
show and got his paycheck for me.
Dead stuff.
I hunted with him.
Yeah.
Did Ya know it was greg manning.
It was a great man.
I'm terrible loss,
terrible loss,
and we talked about it and I,
I shared my knowledge with them.
I'm not,
I don't have an opinion.
It's an animal.
It's dead.
You either revered or you don't utilize
it with respect or you pretend you
didn't have anything to do with it.
It's dead.
You're eating it.
You should have been closer to the
system and the hunters,
fishermen and trappers in this country
still carry on the definitive physics of
spirituality that the native and
aboriginal peoples called the great
spirit.
Hence the spirit of the wild.
The prayer for the wild things.
We're in a weird place,
ted,
with cities,
right?
Right,
right.
You were.
Yeah,
but I mean you got lucky and that your
father was interested in bowhunting and
that it gave him an escape,
which by the way,
it gives a lot of veterans today.
A lot of veterans and good friends of
mine have finding the Lt great relief in
bow hunting as a discipline after
combat.
Yeah,
talking to a guy that's shared mini camp
fires with those guys.
It's a rare last night.
Great transition for them.
It's consuming.
Fred bear uses the phrase coined the
phrase,
and I use it all the time.
It cleanses the soul when you leave the
pavement.
When I leave the pavement and I make
that transition from modern concrete
jungle,
hand to hand combat city guy,
because that's where my rock and roll
career is the ultimate,
and you take that deep breath.
You literally go back to the year one.
I know there's a high we nearby and I
know I can hear trucks off in the
distance and the train whistle,
which is kind of titillated unto itself,
but when I get in my swamp and Michigan
or my woodland,
Texas
to quote Jimi Hendrix and no live
nowhere,
I am the aborigine.
It's me,
my resources and the beast and it's a.
it's a religious experience.
It's the spirit of that natives called
it the great spirit.
Thethe considered the buffalo.
They're brother and it is so consuming
that I don't care what kind of stress
you could be going through the ugliest
divorce in the world and I have.
You could be fighting against people who
don't think that America should be first
and you don't need secure borders and
and you don't need to earn your own way.
You're able bodied,
but you want somebody else's income.
It just crazy shit and all of a sudden I
get out there and I'm telling you,
Joe,
it's perfect and I'm,
I'm literally intoxicated.
I'm,
I'm drunk,
I'm stoned trying to pick up all the
signals and I do.
I do a pretty good job.
I've learned over the years because I
need that so much to play my music like
I play it,
that it cleanses my soul and I've been
contacted since the sixties with vets
who have gone through just absolute
torture in their military careers and
when I get them at a campfire and we go
out and sit before the sun comes up,
I can't tell you how many times they've
cried because it's,
it's good.
Again,
there was a great morning.
I didn't have any stress,
forgot all about that bullshit when I
thought I heard the deer.
Then when I saw the deer,
it was perfect.
So you've expressed that and I thank you
for that because you're new to this
sport and uh,
for you to be an advocate and to
articulate,
you learn because you're already a
mature man.
When you entered it,
I was a dirtball mushy brain kid,
but thank God I learned about that
spirit.
I learned about the discipline.
I learned about stewardship,
callings,
and responsibility course pounded by my
dad.
God bless him.
I'm in my brothers,
my sister.
We all
are happy,
healthy,
successful,
hardworking,
funny,
cocky,
loving,
giving people because of that discipline
that revolved around my family hunting
seasons or discipline is one of the big
word that that was one of the really
important aspects of it because I
recognize the importance of discipline
and always have pretty much my whole
life.
A as a martial artist especially.
Yeah.
So I came into boat.
We're ahead of the.
You were ahead of the curve yet.
When I recognized it,
I was like,
oh,
I know what.
This is a different thing.
This is not what everybody thinks it is.
And this is a,
this is a spiritual experience because
you were around the masters.
Cameron Hanes,
you had John Dudley on over now is one.
It got me.
He's a Michigan boy.
Um,
yeah.
That's,
uh,
that they were good mentors for you.
I got lucky.
You got past the mistaken yet
irresponsibly and dishonestly promoted
aspect of the drunk and hill billy
science shooter hunter.
Well,
that,
that stereotype is so ridiculous.
I mean,
my friends like guys like Cameron Hanes,
he's a Goddamn ultra marathon runner and
I run 240 miles in a week and then you
know,
is on the mountains all fall long.
Bad mofo.
I'm glad he doesn't play guitar.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker across the
board,
but he's.
He's an incredibly disciplined.
Gosh,
this is his life.
His and he.
He'll tell everybody all that stuff that
he does all the working out.
That's so he can be at his best in the
mountains as a bowhunter that he
considers his true spiritual call and I
got to tell you're sitting across from a
guy and I'm not bragging,
I'm just kind of sharing.
You can brag to brag a little bit.
Yeah,
but it's.
It's a celebration.
I have been humbled and blessed beyond
description to share campfires with more
hunters than anybody you've ever met
because I've been donating hunch for
years.
I started,
my son rides the fires.
I guide hundreds of hunters every year.
I don't take them all out to their
stand,
but we all get together at my Michigan
Place,
have 24 and a weekend,
20 and a weekend and it's a campfire.
Get Down with uncle Ted playing guitar,
but we shoot our bows,
we shoot our guns,
we set things up.
A lot of them are newcomers.
I got on my spirit wild ranch in Texas.
I guide in New Brunswick and Ontario for
kid rock into bowhunting.
Yes,
I did.
That was a great story.
He hunted down.
Remember that discipline word.
We're talking about working on that,
but his girlfriend is a killer.
She is a killer.
Gorgeous Gal,
but audrey is a dangerous bull Hutton
woman.
I mean she always killing stuff.
It's tough.
She's addicted.
I get.
I get paced from her all the time and
never from Bob.
That's hilarious.
She's awesome.
I'll start sharing that stuff with your
turn.
You onto a higher level of appreciation
of finance.
Women with a sharp stick.
This gal between my wife,
Charmaine and Audrey,
I'm telling
you.
Yeah,
but anyhow,
the guys that you've hunted with,
you're talking about great human beings,
men of integrity and discipline and
productivity and a drive to be in the
asset column misunderstood because of
movies.
Very rarely I.
I get it.
I was about to say I shared campfires
with lots of newcomers because they see
it as rock and roll guy that they loved
the music and we share the appreciation
for my American rhythm and blues rock
and roll Jihad,
and so they want to try hunting and they
come to my hunt with me or they make a
donation for a military or children's
charity and they've never hunted and I'd
tell them what to buy and they show up
and it's natty bumppo man who natty
bumppo.
No need to get into that.
Okay,
I'll write that down too,
and now I'm going to sell.
I'm going to send it to you.
James Fenimore Cooper.
He was a character in his last of
Mohicans.
It's a new hunter,
natty Bumppo,
like a novice of rookie.
Anyhow,
I get a lot of these people and you
know,
I've never met anybody at any of my
campfires that wasn't honest,
that wasn't friendly,
wasn't successful to some degree,
whether it's a teacher on a teacher
salary,
successful.
There are teacher that's successful
who care deeply about the wildlife and
the wild grounds.
So when you hear about wow,
that drunk and bombs,
just shooting everything,
well,
nobody has spent more time with more
hunters than I have.
I've never seen that even
exists.
It exists sort of priests that.
But fuck kids,
you know,
but that's not the priesthood,
right?
I hope so.
There's always going to be Aberman dip,
shit,
demonic behavior by our fellow man
somewhere somehow.
But it is so rare in the hunting world
that I,
again,
I,
it's all.
I do seven months a year as hunt.
Well,
I haven't hunted as much as you,
but I've been around a lot of great
people.
Great people.
Yeah.
And then it goes right back to fred
bear,
which is the start off of our dialogue
here.
Great man.
We hunted until 1987 together in October
and he was on oxygen.
Then he passed away.
Have you ever heard the song?
Yeah.
Song.
And then that song happened with a life
of its own because of my love and
admiration for the man and what he
represented,
someone like that,
that just carries that torch further
than everyone that at times we were so
important at time where there was no
indication that you have to.
The animal rights thing hadn't really
started,
um,
meaningfully yet.
Um,
political correctness,
which wasn't even coined.
There was no fake news.
There was the beginning of the attack on
hunting from,
you know,
ignorant,
citified,
people that somehow believed that their
food didn't die or they're not
responsible for any death.
And so they would play the holier
than now dishonesty move by attacking
those of us that actually took part in
the process of feeding our families.
And Fred was such a gentleman and he was
so clever and he so efficiently promoted
the challenge and the intimacy of man
and wild connection that uh,
he will live in infamy.
Uh,
everybody in the hunting world knows
that he was a force to reckon with and
he's always there and as the song says
in the wind,
he still alive and it's powerful that a
lot of people know of him because of you
or.
Yeah,
a lot people.
More people have learned about Fred from
me than from the archery industry.
Yeah.
Do you,
do you this,
this conversation you've been having
this conversation about hunting forever.
I mean,
I've heard a lot of these things that
you're saying today before from you.
Does this the ever get tired of seeing
this evangelist?
No.
I love it so much and the other side is
so dishonest that I know I make inroads.
Yoda,
my facebook,
I'm dishonest.
Or you think they're ignorant.
They know that.
They know that there's going to be new
funds next year,
but there's not gonna be any new ground.
They know this.
They know that venison is good food,
but they don't think of it that way.
That's why I continue to do this because
I caused them to think.
I can tell you thousands of examples
since the sixties where people thought I
was a coward for murdering innocent
animals that can't shoot back.
I mean,
what does that sentence even mean?
What it mean to catch you back and left
trigger fingers yet jerk.
So I have taken this on and you notice
it.
I smiled throughout that whole thing.
I don't get angry.
I'm so.
I know that by continuing to promote in
the absence of any education and our
education system,
in fact,
it's the opposite.
Animal rights gets more time in our
education system.
Our anti-education is the media lion,
sons of bitches,
Hollywood goofy,
half of the government out to lunch,
so you guys like you and me that know
the truth.
We should never give up because there is
a scourge of political correctness and
dishonesty,
and that's what political correctness
is.
Denial and dishonesty,
and I know we're making inroads.
You should see the bombardment.
I got Joseph big hunter now.
He's really a fighter.
He speak cleverly,
speaks accurately and and passionately
about it.
Hallelujah.
There's a bunch of us out there with the
advent of the outdoor channel and
sportsmans channel,
the pursuit network.
Uh,
more and more people are getting,
you know,
wind of what we're doing.
I think a lot of it from the Internet to
end,
the monster communication people,
I think people understand that there's
more to it than they thought.
And if they're willing to just look a
little bit further,
look a little bit further,
they realized like,
well,
especially western hunting.
Yeah.
These guys are running hills and
they're,
they're backpacking with heavy weights
on their back discipline for hours and
hours everyday just to build up their
endurance and they can hike out with,
meet these western hunters.
Man that are going.
MOFO is.
Yeah,
bow hunting elk and then packing them
out by themselves over the course of
five days.
Credible job.
I went to Alaska first time when I was
20 something,
I guess I must've been 28,
my first Alaska trip 77 and I was out
there for two weeks in a soggy,
wet,
nasty cold tent,
a little pup tent with George Fairbury
and I got a giant Caribou,
a great black bear in a big old moose
and boy humping them quarters in that,
that Tundra,
uh,
yeah.
I thought I was a superman athletic
amplifier,
jumping,
rock and roll.
So new muscle boy,
my ass kicked,
carrying a moose shoulder.
$100 a quarter.
Just one big moose.
And you see one in real life.
It's hard to believe that that's a real
animal.
And that goes back to what you were
saying earlier,
that when you dine on that and you put
that effort forth and you spent all
those days skunked and wet and cold and
nasty,
enjoying it for what it was,
but it was also a pain in the ass.
You can't get wait to get back to some
place with a wood burner,
but when you've packed it out yourself,
when you take that sacred flesh off that
grill,
before you even finished the first
knife,
slice all those memories and it just
tastes better and it really does taste
better,
but with that effort,
it is a spiritual moment that this
linkedin native say you don't kill the
animal.
You accept the gift if you put your
heart and soul into your reasoning
Predator ship,
and that's always been my mantra and my
kids were all raised on Venison at,
we just don't buy meat.
That's all we eat is the stuff.
We kill a pheasants and quail and Doug's
and woodcock and grouse and rabbits and
squirrels and ducks and geese and
galloon mules and snipe and beavers and
deer and elk and antelope and bear and
Cougar.
That's the greatest food in the world.
I'm 70 years old and I'm forced to
reckon with because of my discipline
diet of the ultimate rocket fuel
available.
Unplanned.
You really do look good for 17.
Fucking fantastic.
If I had some sleep,
I'd be downright handsome,
but you think about,
you know the average person that's been
eating the average American diet for 70
years old,
by the time they're your age,
they're deteriorating,
rapidly poisoned,
the fruit toast to the chemicals,
the preservatives.
Oh my God.
Here's if I may on the Joe Rogan
podcast,
please do my friends.
Get rid of the goddamn sugar.
If you can't pronounce it on the
package,
do not buy it.
Do not feed your children high fruit
toast poisoning.
My God,
people get the poisons out of your
blubbering lives.
Good food is so simple by what?
Catch a fish or buy
a fish by some fresh or grow some fresh
vegetables.
Put real butter and use the real fat.
Don't take the skin off the chicken.
That's where all the good fat is.
That's where all the flavor is and eat
real food.
Wow.
We can't afford that.
No.
You can't afford not to everything that
says diet on it or no sugar is poison
and it's not my opinion.
It's a chemical reality and when you,
when you died,
when you attempt to digest fructose and
preservatives,
you're body goes,
I don't recognize this bullshit.
We can't process this,
and it turns into blubber and here's a
little update.
Blubber is for sperm whales,
not people.
If you have to lift up slabs to dry off
after the shower,
your diet sucks.
I saw you in an interview once,
a long time ago before I started
watching.
I've done a bunch of them.
I know you have,
but when I saw you I was like,
how's this guy have so much fucking
energy?
I remember thinking that like,
this guy is so fired up,
and then he started talking about your
diet started talking about.
He said,
all I eat is venison.
You start going off about backstraps and
then I started thinking like what?
Like think about the dark red meat of
wild game before you became 100.
Quite a few years before.
I flirted with it for several years,
he flirted with.
I didn't have anybody to take get a swan
dive into it.
I got lucky Steve to me with a mask on
his show.
I know Steve doesn't like me,
but he's like,
Huh?
Why say he doesn't like you.
I've heard comments with is attacking me
for the whack 'em and stack 'em because
he wouldn't be much better if I just
butchered them and slaughtered them
because semantics is so important.
Oh,
W,
the way you phrase things,
waggaman snack on.
It's fun.
I'm whacking,
I'm stacking.
I got 12 bluegills.
That's back.
Shut the fuck up.
Well,
do people think that you were outrageous
behavior or somehow detrimental to the
movement of acceptance?
Stupid people do,
but the people who come and join the
sport because of my exuberance don't.
Well,
I would say that godless,
blessed Brunello and God bless Cameron.
All those guys,
I revere them.
They're masters of their craft.
I have caused more young people to
become hunters than all other forces in
the world.
Case closed because I'm having so much
fucking fun.
They go,
hey,
this guy's out of control.
Bows and arrows don't kill something.
They absolutely come to it because of
the fund.
Then they hear about the discipline and
hear about the quality diet and they
hear about their spiritual trophy,
whether antlers or not,
that has guided my passionate life and
manifest itself in these killer songs
and killer guitar licks and outrageous
fire-breathing concerts and they go,
oh fuck,
I can do that,
and so they get a bone marrow.
They shouldn't get a shotgun.
They started hunting.
Go to my facebook.
I don't know if it's millions,
but found thousands and thousands of
young people that would be inclined to
be anti hunting or no gun Ho hunters
because uncle Ted is having so much fun
because I whacked them and them.
Well,
congratulations with that.
Yeah.
The the.
The thing is that they don't get.
When they hear your enthusiasm,
then they go,
okay,
well I haven't had this perspective
before.
Their perspective on hunting that I've
gotten before is that these are cruel
assholes that go out there and shoot
animals and they don't care and or worse
or worse.
Joe,
that my critics,
and I won't mention any names,
but you know,
when they're on,
they're a hunting TV shows and they're
so ultra cautious not to ruffle any
feathers.
They kind of come off like Mr Rogers
with a Lawrence welk soundtrack.
And young people think you're a fucking
asshole if that's all you've got in a
hunting.
Is that boring?
I think I'll just smoke some dope and
go,
you know,
cruzen tonight,
which I know you like to smoke dope.
And uh,
and I'll call it dope and go nuts.
Do you call it?
Well,
I'm a cop.
Yeah,
there you go.
Well,
but I got buddies for that.
I just don't think that comfortably numb
is the way to go.
In fact,
I have a solid song I ever.
Well,
you know a better song on my new record.
It's called uncomfortably dumb.
My point is,
is,
are you a father?
Yes.
You want your babysitter high?
Uh,
no.
How about your doctor?
No pilot.
I don't want my babysitter sleeping
either.
You don't her what?
Sleeping.
I want them paying attention.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
get high ever.
It just means you shouldn't get high
when you're watching kids.
Damn.
Right.
Yeah.
Or when you're flying my plane or I play
Bass Guitar.
The only compromise me doing anything
delicate.
You know,
the only guy want high who?
My comedians.
Uh,
it helps.
It's like steroids.
I was there when Richard Pryor and Robin
Williams and Sam Kinison,
God knows.
Go ahead and snort anything you got
motherfucker because I need to laugh.
Delay Shit.
It's hard to come out.
But that shit sober
every night.
I'm a funny son of a bitch.
You gotta come see my show.
I have so much fun on stage.
It's stupid.
I think that perceptions about pot are
very similar to the perceptions about.
There's a lot of people that abused pot,
they abused alcohol abuse.
People will abuse every.
Sure.
It doesn't mean you can't use it
responsibly.
I agree.
Um,
unfortunately in my 60 years of pursuing
the Chuck Berry Soundtrack of Ultra
James Brown type music,
I have never seen anything but
heartbreak from drugs,
from the drug use.
Even in.
I'm on a new council by the way of
working with President trump to legalize
medical marijuana nationwide.
We don't want you to know that and I'm
all for that.
That was awesome.
I deal with a lot of terminally ill kids
and there's nothing that's off limits.
Take away that suffering.
So I need to fight for that.
Well,
it's great for people with epilepsy as
well.
A lot of kids.
Kids have autism.
I got my bag out in the truck.
Um,
some guys making water with cannabis oil
with the CDB is that part of CBD and
sizzle.
Helped me relax after my sonic bombast
tortured gassed on stage every night.
I'm sure it,
they got to drink some of that shit.
Well,
I know you've had some problems with
your knees and stand both new knees and
both of them,
you know,
jumping off all those amps.
I never knew.
I never heard the word meniscus still.
My doctor said I had none.
I have a tear on mine.
I just got a stem cell shots in it
yesterday.
I have two brand new knees and uh,
I end dancing like the 25 year old Ted
nugent.
But you're walking fine.
I'm doing fine.
So I used to have a bad limp right from
that shuffle.
Yeah.
And now we're both gone.
Steve Tyler was here from aerosmith and
he's got a new one.
He's got one new one and he's thinking
about getting another one.
Have both the same time.
Yeah.
How long were you down for?
Um,
I was walking the next morning.
So what do they do exactly?
Well,
they're going to cut your knee open and
they get a hammer and a chisel and they
found out the old shit and put in some
metal stuff.
Have you ever seen this actually
available online?
You don't want to watch it if you're
going to have it done.
Oh,
it's brutal.
But I had a good surgeon and uh,
it came out good.
And the pain going on stage for so many
years since certainly since the year.
2,000 with the Damn Yankees.
Even.
What year did you get it done?
A 2000.
18?
No.
12 maybe.
So 12 years of pain?
Yeah,
oh it was,
it was more than that,
but because I jumped off those fucking
amplifiers.
Blew your knees out.
Oh my.
What kind of dirt bag was I?
Somebody should have said you have
meniscus will you know,
discuss,
you know Maynard Keenan,
the lead singer of tool,
right.
He blew his hip out from just stomping
on the ground because the music.
I have a new record called the music
made me do it.
The music made him do it.
There's music made Steve.
Tyler do it.
When you get up there,
it is a world unto itself.
It is out of body is stream of
consciousness.
It you got to be careful because you
think you're invincible.
Invincible on net stage with Weiwei way
that movie invincible.
They use stranglehold.
Best use of my song ever.
But anyhow.
Best use of your song ever was randy
coture coming out to stranglehold in the
UFC?
Yeah,
you're probably right.
Yes,
I remember that.
Yes.
And the Black Hawks in Chicago,
every gigs for the 25,
30 years,
they came out the stranglehold when he
beat Tim Silvia for the UFC heavyweight
title,
severe undercard underdog.
And he came out and the place went nuts
when he says it all to here,
like come again,
a baby like a dog in heat to me by the
clamor baby.
And I'd like to
tear up the street.
I've been smoking for so long.
I'm here to stay.
I've got you in a stranglehold bitch.
Get the fuck out of my way.
Fucking awesome.
You're getting.
You're getting excited.
It's a love song.
The connection between rock and roll.
Guitarist and bow hunting.
For most people it's like a big stretch
to stretch.
It's like what are those different
galaxies?
Different universities,
except for the most important elements
in that is discipline.
Discipline,
the focus to create an.
I've been so blessed beyond words to
have the greatest musicians at my side
for ever for literally 60 years right
now.
I got Greg Smith on the Bass Guitar.
Just a god of thunder.
Greg Smith the best,
like a funk brother and heat and Jason
heartless.
Twenty three year old drummer from
Detroit is just an absolute animal.
And every band from my royal high boys
and the fifties to the lords in the
sixties.
And the Amboy dukes and even the Damn
Yankees with Tommy and Jack and Michael.
Are you kidding me?
I've had literally the,
a list of musicians at my side from
Tommy Aldridge and Tommy [inaudible] and
make brown and drums and,
and,
and cliff Davis.
Are you kidding me?
Denny Car Masiya.
I mean the best drummers,
the best bass players.
I've just been the luckiest guitar
player in the.
But it's a weird connection,
right?
Like most people don't think of rock and
roll and bow hunting at the same thing
you do.
You're the only one.
But there I was geographically in
Michigan,
uh,
a firestorm of musical influence to all
the best musicians in the world.
They'll tell you,
come out of Detroit from Motown,
Bob Seger.
Now Kid Rock,
eminem.
And just just killer,
killer bands.
Mc Five.
I got a great Wayne Kramer Story.
He has a wonderful book coming out
called the hard stuff you ever talked to
Wayne,
you need to have Wayne Kramer on your
show.
He kisses him from New York,
the MC five,
but at rock city I'm thinking,
yeah,
I'm going to turn you onto Wayne Kramer.
Has got a book about his tragic mistakes
and near death,
heroine prison,
dirt bag maneuvers,
but he's a great man,
a musical authority,
and in the music of Detroit and of
course fifties little Richard.
How do you not get moved by little
Richard and Bo Diddley and Chuck Berry?
How do you not how he had not touched by
that and then you see him on tv and the
Ed Sullivan show it.
I don't care who you are.
Steven,
Tyler,
Billy Joel or whoever,
you know,
Elvis Presley and now the stones and the
Beatles.
Are you kidding me?
On Ed Sullivan and I had a guitar plus
I'm in Michigan and I every kid was
born.
You got a red rider,
daisy bb gun.
You had a Wemo slingshot and you had a
little bone Arrow of some kind.
I live right next to the rouge river,
so I was always down there,
you know,
chase and critters and building forts
and crossing the river and the music and
the bowhunting music in the bowhunting.
I met Fred Bear.
I got these great musicians,
the music and the bowhunting music and
the book.
Unbelievable.
What a life,
what a dream,
what a firestorm of cravings and
fulfillment of those cravings everyday.
And here it is.
Last night mares my 6680th concert and
it goes all the way back to Stockholm.
All counter to all the way back to the
19 fifties,
60,600.
You write them down now.
I did for years.
I took out all the books and start
adding them up.
But from the,
from my,
uh,
a musical review with the Royal School
of music in 1958.
And then with Joe [inaudible] from the
Capital School of music at the Detroit
fairgrounds.
And then we started playing sock hops
and pool parties and malt shops and
everywhere,
you know,
basement parties.
I counted those,
those are gigs.
And then when the amboy dukes started in
[inaudible] 65,
we'd do 300 concerts,
three plus 300 a year for many,
many years.
And then even with the Damn Yankees and
the early nineties we did over 200
concerts a year.
So I added them all up.
And last year was 6,679 in Okinawa for
the US Marine Corps.
Pretty intense.
And then last night at the coach house
in San Juan Capistrano,
6,680 to 96,
six 81.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Cool.
That's why I look tired.
That's a lot of things in remedy.
How do you have the time?
Because I always figured out,
I tried to figure out how I have the
time to do what I do,
but I think you do more than I do.
Uh,
I think we can both agree.
The greatest philosopher of all times
was dirty Harry when he said a good man
knows his limitations
back in the [inaudible] with the Amboy
Dukes,
we do over 300 concerts a year and I was
still craving my hunting.
So I'd,
I'd carve out a weekend in October and a
weekend in November with my dad and we'd
get out there and hunt.
But that wasn't enough.
What about practice time with the
archery?
Ida Bone Arrow on the road block target.
Met in a parking lot somewhere.
Morel targets for morale and it's got a
spot,
but no,
I've shot my bow and Arrow on stage with
thousands of contracts and then I always
have it with me and I always have
friends that have bows and arrows.
In fact,
I wish I had brought it today because I
could show you some this zen of mystical
flight of the Arab maneuvers.
They had a really lightweight bowl,
only 50 pounds.
That new matthews.
I shoot the new triax manager.
There's not a bad bill out there.
Not Anymore.
The competition is awesome.
So anybody listening to the most
important thing you can tell,
Joe and I love the mystical flight of
the Arrow.
Go get you a bow and Arrow shop fire
hazard.
Find a bowl that fits you and make sure
it's graceful enough.
Don't struggle when you're starting to.
We've got to come back.
Mushy.
Archery is grace,
not power and get that bow so it settles
back here for hand.
Eye Coordination,
and you don't have to struggle.
People should start with a 25,
30 pound bow to get that archery thing
going.
Preferably an old recover long boy if
you can and find out where you're
pointing,
where's that Arrow going and you will be
consumed with it
and then work your way.
You can really teach you if you have to
have a mentor because if you do it wrong
and you start with a bad,
bad habits will plague you.
Then you could target panic.
Well,
it's a.
that's a problem with martial arts too.
It's really important to start off with
a good instructor if you learn things
poorly first and then try to fix it,
but you're still kind of wired
incorrectly.
It's very difficult and archery as well,
right?
That's why America is in trouble because
people are learning at schools.
That's a really good analogy.
I mean really learning the wrong stuff.
I mean,
it really is what's going on.
You know,
you get taught that life is boring,
droning.
Pay attention to the rules.
Show me,
show me a graduate from the American
anti-education system that can balance a
checkbook.
Does people do that anymore where they
ought to know?
Unfortunately they don't hedge the debt.
You know,
pragmatism went the way of maps,
but you know what I mean.
I'd be pragmatic.
Be Responsible,
be accountable.
Be Utilitarian.
Self be the best that you can be.
Call your body the sacred temple that
it's supposed to be treated with
reverence,
eat good,
be good,
be the best that you can be.
Be Competitive.
Life isn't fair.
Get used to it.
If you want to excel in life,
you show up earlier than the
competition.
You work harder than competition.
You do a better job than the
competition.
You stay later than the competition.
You'll end up owning the damn company.
Yeah,
and learning how to think.
Learning how to think and learning how
to look at things.
It's something that's never taught in
school and it's one of the most
important lessons in your life and you
learn that lesson,
I think through doing difficult things.
Absolutely.
I had a conversation about you once and
someone was like,
well,
what do you think?
He's like,
I go,
look,
this is what you have to understand.
Forget about all the public shit.
He's awesome at two things that are
really hard to be good at.
Guitar in Bowhunting,
very difficult.
Both very difficult to be disciplined.
You have to be an exceptional person,
especially since you sound like such
shit for so long and the guitar,
there's no satisfaction whatsoever.
You go out for how many years took
years.
I was the worst.
All my buddies learned faster than I
did.
In fact,
I just met up with Donnie Henderson.
He's probably listening right now and he
was in a band called the gang when I had
a band called the lawyers.
We kicked their ass and won the battle
of the bands in Michigan when I was
about 13 or 14 and he and I are still
friends and he's.
I guess he's going to be 70 soon too,
and he played all the Chuck Berry and Bo
diddly stuff.
Perfect.
And I'm stumbling and making stupid
noises,
but you know what happened because I
couldn't figure out the exact licks.
I created my own style and I started
playing.
People thought I was being clever.
I just wasn't doing them wrong,
but it still had a good rhythm at a kind
of cool Santa.
Yeah.
Like John Coltrain meets,
you know,
a punk kid play in bodiddly licks,
and so I developed my own style and I've
had a lot of fun with it.
But with all your question is though,
with all your media,
all the stuff that you
do,
you're,
you're constantly doing interviews and
phone interviews.
You're constantly doing things.
How do you have time to do all this?
Still write music.
I have a great team.
You were talking about Linda getting
ahold of your team.
Linda Peters have been with me for 30
years.
Uh,
Doug Bankers,
been my manager for over 30 years of all
my crew,
Chris Helms and Jim nap and my sons and
my daughters.
Um,
my wife Charmaine is the goddess.
If you ever seen Shane,
sure God help me.
Senior show.
Oh,
she's so good.
And she's the queen of the forest.
He is the queen of the forest.
Full time.
Not a damn thing you can do about it.
And I have such a great team.
My crew on the road right now.
I leave nothing to chance.
I don't have to worry or think about a
thing.
All I have to do is play my guitar and
rock my balls off,
so I always had a great team,
professional work ethic,
monsters that are conscientious.
I'm dedicated,
professional,
knowledgeable,
so there's no loose ends and that's how
I'm able to do all.
You're this,
but you're also this really loud voice
in the culture war have to be,
you know,
you have to be.
I,
I refuse to let lives go unchallenged.
I refuse to let antilogic going.
Challenged antilogic like what?
Like did you.
You don't need secure borders really.
So the Democrats,
I think we need to secure our borders
and the Democrats don't admit there's a
difference between legal immigration and
illegal immigration.
Let me give you a little metaphor.
If you go to the bank and withdraw from
your account,
your illegal banker,
if you go to the bank and draw from
someone else's account,
you're a bank robber.
That was a division.
There were four of legal banking.
We're not for illegal banking and this
kind of antilogic has weaseled his way
into policy and it's just tragic with
the multi trillion dollar debt and
unsecured borders and we're worried
about separating families,
which we failed to say.
If you're going to come here,
come legally are we will send you back.
We send out a message,
have edit.
Just go ahead and implement across the
dam river.
Well,
do you personally have a problem when
they separate families?
Because I'm a father and a grandfather.
Yeah,
the fucked up.
But the real fuck up starts with the,
the,
the insane irresponsibility of daring to
subject your children to that.
I don't think they have any choice at a
dinner over there.
They live in
Mexico and Guatemala is one big gang
infested government.
Military law enforcement.
Shithole.
Yeah.
And if you call it a shit hole,
I'm racist.
Well,
if it wasn't a shit hole,
they would stay.
It is a shit hole.
You ever been there?
Well,
some,
some.
Uh,
Mexico is also.
Some of the Mexico hasn't been raped and
pillaged yet,
but give them time.
They'll make it that even in the big
resorts they're murdering and raping and
bureau realizing people.
I mean,
it's just a hell hole.
There's definitely some bad things
happen in a lot of it is because of the
drug war out of control.
Yeah,
and a lot of people think that the
remedy to that is legalizing drugs and
taxing man.
Yeah.
So I mean the same thing with
prohibition.
Same thing that would happen in America
really boosted organized crime and Al
Capone and they.
They got a stronghold because of the
money they were making from illegal
drugs or alcohol at the time.
I think that right now that the spoiled
Brat epidemic in this country,
if you don't get everything,
you want you to start shooting people or
cut people off and road rage if
everything doesn't go just right.
Everybody is so touchy and so pussified
that when I was growing up,
sticks and stones may break your bones,
but words will never hurt me.
What do you think that's coming from the
liberalization of policy and the the
horrible lie of the welfare dream that
people who need a helping hand are
always given a helping hand by neighbors
and family and friends,
and if they have.
Well,
the Catholic Church has
$8,000,000,000,000 just in jewelry.
They could probably provide some
sandwiches and blankets so there's
plenty of help available,
but when you get into a system and you,
you play on the people's emotions that
we need a safety net,
these poor people are just too.
You need help.
Okay,
let's create a welfare where we can help
these destitute people.
Meanwhile,
it's infested with scammers and blood
suckers and liars who are abled bodied
and they just don't want to stop it to
help.
One is sign.
They want some of your income because
you're stupid enough to get up early and
work really hard and they don't want to.
That's pandemic.
So meanwhile the people who are truly
needy,
they slipped through the cracks.
We don't even get to know who they are
and and the the liberal policy of
eliminating the heartbreak and the
disrespect of Cuckoo's nest.
We can.
We can call them mental health centers.
We might hurt some feelings.
So now what are they doing?
They're putting spikes in boards and
attacking people,
walking their dog and La.
He said there's no place for them to go.
When I was growing up,
there's a place in Detroit called a
[inaudible].
It was a nuthouse and that's the
Cuckoo's nest.
That's where if you were mentally ill
and you needed help that there was a
place for you to go to get you off the
streets so you don't attack people with
spikes in Dubai.
What are you talking about?
The spikes in right here,
right down the street here.
One,
two days ago.
Tact some,
a fashion photographer walking his dog
and hit him in the head with a two by
four with a spike and almost killed him
in a.
In a citizen.
I didn't even hear about it.
Oh yeah.
It was awesome.
Citizen jumped up in the air and caught
this guy with both feet right in the
neck and neck.
Beat the shit out of him.
It was awesome.
That's nice.
That was a rare occasion of justice.
Pro Wrestling comes in handy,
but yes,
but that,
that incident is not rare where you go
to San Francisco and the mental health
institution isn't supposed to be the
streets.
That mental health is a good example of
too much liberal policy.
You get people that are a little bit too
progressive and
regressive.
I don't know.
How did they ever utilize that term
that's bastardized as progressive?
It gets so far that it becomes
regressive when you're letting bombed
shit all over the streets.
But thank you.
I think that would be an indicator.
So there's.
So the idea is that just like these poor
people leave them alone,
you know,
they're fine.
They just,
you know,
it's okay if they live on the streets,
but if you go to San Francisco,
they're very aggressive.
It's one of the weirdest places I've
ever been in terms of homeless people
and one of the most heartbreaking
unquote progressive places in our
country.
So one of the most progressive cities,
heartbreaking.
We need more cuckoo's nest,
but even those institutions,
the corruption and the abuse of power
that runs ramp into nurse Cratchit and
that,
that wasn't just a fantasy scrip that
happens the irresponsibility and in,
in pharmaceutical,
everybody,
you know,
they got a mental problem and then they
increased the mental problem with big
farm.
I mean,
I've had personal experiences with that
with dear friends of mine that were
having mental problems and they end up
in an institution and then their mental
problems are exasperated by chemical
warfare upon them.
You don't.
When I was growing up,
how old are you,
Joe?
Fifty slash 50 just to boy.
Um,
when I was growing up there was this,
this mantra,
this colloquialism better living through
chemistry in many ways it is.
I mean,
we saved tens of millions of lives in
Africa with DDT by killing the Zec fly
and we save tens of millions of people.
And then some environmentalist come in
and the DDT is a dangerous chemical,
so they stopped it and we lost tens of
millions of people.
It's better to kill a bunch of seats.
He flies to save human lives than to
band the DDT.
That allows tsetse flies to flourish and
kills people.
Uh,
so now it's gone full circle and that's
where the toxins have accumulated and
the,
the horrific waste that I had texted
anthony just before he died,
congratulating him,
hunt his hosting that brilliant
documentary if you haven't seen it yet,
it's waste,
waste,
exclamation point,
what we do to where foods in this
country and the self inflicted scourge
of,
of toxification,
of our precious environment.
So there's not a lot of easy answers.
But here it is,
28th of June,
2018.
And here you and I are at least
discussing this stuff to millions of
people,
I suspect.
And I see upgrade taking place.
I see upgrade in awareness,
uh,
not fast enough to make me happy,
but,
uh,
enough to indicate an upgraded prognosis
for people's awareness,
accountability,
responsibility.
Where,
where are you seeing this?
Uh,
whether it's,
you know,
like the circles that you travel circles
certainly in
we don't waste.
One of my biggest pet peeves is little
fat kids that,
you know,
take a sip of $2 bottle of water and
then they leave it there and ended up
throwing it away and the waist is
pandemic in this country and I see my,
my kids are like,
like storm troopers there,
like drill sergeants with that we just
don't want to waste and we've always
recycled and the jury is still out,
whether that has any effect at all.
But the,
the,
the disconnect in unconscionable
misbehavior of just tossing and throwing
away everything.
You know,
what drives me fucking crazy.
Cigarettes out the window.
People just went.
The people that smoke cigarettes for
whatever reason,
to have a problem throwing it on the
ground,
he wouldn't let her.
How about what drives me crazy?
There's somebody still stupid enough to
buy cancer.
Yeah,
exactly.
Here,
let me invest in the companies that want
to kill me here.
Here's a couple extra thousand dollars.
Kill more of us.
Strange.
Cool.
It makes it look a rebel man.
Well,
I've never smoked.
I've never smoked a cigarette.
No drugs,
no drugs,
no alcohol?
No.
You drink a little wine though.
Fat Pussy.
I'm telling you,
that shit will kill you know families.
No,
not even a little allergic.
I'm a big fan for those who want,
but no,
I drink a little wine though.
I do drink a little wine,
but I don't think that qualifies as a
drink.
Having a glass of wine with my sons and
my daughters,
my brothers and sisters,
they Thanksgiving dinner.
Beer.
Beer is better than coke,
right?
Vastly.
Sure.
It's when you start to enter the drool
zone that I have a big problem of
course,
and all of a sudden if there's a
problem,
I can't rely on you anymore.
I want to be reliable and that's why I
have a problem with comfortably numb.
Yeah.
I think in my experience,
you can't wake up the bass player
because he was comfortably numb.
The guys don't show up.
You can't tune his guitar.
He forgot.
The lyrics were not as tight as we could
be.
You're fired.
I know what you're saying,
but this is what I'm saying to you is
that this is just a discipline issue and
it's not the marijuana or anything that
gets people like that.
It's a lack of discipline.
I think Jitsu world and the Jujitsu
world is filled with people that smoked
pot and these motherfuckers work hard.
They want.
What's the number one karate guy?
Who was the guy that died personally?
Yeah.
Bruce Lee.
Did he smoke dope?
Uh,
he ate hash.
The Hash.
Yeah.
You know,
he's into eating half.
Here's my question,
but that's not what killed them.
Here's my question to you is I offered
to my son Rocco,
because he's an advocate of marijuana.
Yes.
Okay.
And I said,
Rocco.
and I said,
so do you really believe that?
Perfectly clean and sober [inaudible]
taking care of your health with a
conscientious diet,
good athletic workout,
discipline,
physical prowess,
[inaudible].
Do you really think that an outside
source,
payoti mushrooms,
dope,
whatever you want to call it,
do you really think that with that
outside influence you can do something
you can't do unto your God given gift,
individual self?
I'm convinced,
Joe,
that you will be the absolute best you
can be.
You will accomplish what I think is a
self inflicted curse of modern man,
that 90 percent,
98 percent of humanity might be tapping
into five percent of their capabilities
because they get on a treadmill.
They get into a paradigm self restricted
pier nine ever so decreasing a view of
the world and experiences and the
overwrote,
the destroyed road over traveled versus
not only the road less traveled,
but the non road untraveled.
That's my favorite.
I'm convinced that you,
Joe Rogan
will find your superior definitive best
without any outside influence.
I believe you have the power.
I think I have the power when I get
onstage tonight and you gotta come you
gotta come witness this,
but my bed and I do like it out.
We'll figure out a time.
I can't come tonight.
It's like Italy.
I got an orgy.
So at the Improv of human fire,
we put our fists together and chant
James Brown and Wilson Pickett and funk
brothers and it's like the last wolves
on an island gun gnashing of teeth over
the last bone.
And Charlotte of flesh,
it's,
it's a,
it's an out of body
soaring above life itself.
Experience that we have in us.
I don't need anything.
I understand me,
I understand that.
But you don't use anything,
so you're talking from a place of non
experience when it comes to marijuana or
mushrooms or any of these things.
But my 70 years,
I'd say at least 55 of those years from
the beatniks to the hippies,
to the,
to the friends.
And you got to meet this Wayne Kramer,
guide Mc five guitars,
new book,
the hard stuff.
He and I were born the same time,
same influenced Detroit,
the swamps,
the outdoors,
but bodiddly,
Chuck Berry,
Motown,
James Brown.
He started smoking dope.
I didn't.
And he's a any.
Got Heroin and had any prison again.
And then arrested and I'm having the
time of my life and he's like wallowing
in a cesspool of dog shit.
And I'm not knocking Wayne.
I'm saying that he was courageous to
write this book.
It's a brilliant book.
You got to have them on.
You're going to read it.
You're gonna.
You're going to be consumed
by his conversational writing of the MC
five's a ascension to the most
authoritative power house music I've
ever witnessed in my life,
to a bunch of dirt bags on the downward
spiral because of drugs and alcohol.
I know that happens.
It definitely happens,
but it happens with everything.
It happens with people when they eat too
much food.
It happens with people with gambling.
It happens in different things,
but I think it's because of discipline.
It's because they don't have a clear
path.
I think it's because they let themselves
become self indulgent and they let
themselves be weak,
but I'm saying is that I know a lot of
people who use,
whether it's psychedelics or they use
marijuana and they use it to enhance
their perspective.
It doesn't become the primary focus of
their life.
It doesn't consume their life.
They don't allow it to consume their
life.
There's a whole other world of
disciplined marijuana enthusiasts and
they're confused.
Same way people confuse hunter's the
same way.
People think of hunters as being lazy.
Drunk and slavs were cruel to animals
and you and I know that that's not the
case at all,
some of the most disciplined focused and
just people in the world,
intense people because to be,
to be at Cameron Hanes,
to be a John Dudley,
you have to be a superior type of human
being super athletes.
You have to be able to execute in that
extreme moment,
that moment where that animal walks out
into that shooting window and you're
looking at this three 90 bull elk
screaming,
overwhelming all over itself over
whelming and it's 40 yards away and your
center in that pen.
It takes magical,
powerful human being to execute that
shot and I don't think most people are
aware of that.
Most people don't know in the same way
that that's misunderstood.
I think marijuana is misunderstood
because there's a lot of dummies in this
world.
If you get a group of 100 people,
what are the odds that one of them is
going to be a dummy?
Fucking 100 percent,
right?
One hundred percent nowadays more than
one.
Well,
if you get a group of 100 people that
use marijuana,
the one loud fucking stupid one defies
or defines rather what marijuana users
are.
You see that fucking idiot who's pissing
all over himself and fallen down so high
you can't walk.
That's what you think of.
You don't think of the Brazilian Jujitsu
black belt that smokes pot and then goes
out and strangles 50 people in class.
You don't think of people that take yoga
class.
I liked hiring marijuana.
Strangling there should be.
Listen,
I'm absorbing,
absorbing,
in,
respecting and considering your work.
It can get away from you can get away
from you.
All I've ever said,
everything can get away from you.
That's all I've ever seen,
but I think it's because these people
that consume it,
they don't have those other qualities.
They don't have discipline and focus.
They don't have respect for their body.
See,
the thing with the,
especially in the Jujitsu community,
it's super common.
Marijuana is really,
really,
really common.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a show called high rollers where
these guys,
they put together a Jujitsu tournament
and everybody had to get high before
they rolled and you're talking like
elite world class Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belts competing high on marijuana,
and that's got to be one of the highest
forms of disciplines very available to
us.
It's a very,
very.
With the camera and climbing bowhunting
Coleen and milk in your lap.
Well you're,
you're,
you're doing an art that's designed to
break bodies and the two of you are
going to do it together and the whole
idea is that you're going to get someone
into a position where they have to tap
or they're going to get their arm
snapped or they're going to get choked.
Unconscious said intense.
Extremely difficult pursuit and a lot of
people do it under the influence of
marijuana.
Do you know any of these master Jujitsu
martial artists?
Oh yeah.
Fit that.
Don't do any.
Oh yeah.
And how did they perform?
They perform well.
Do very well.
There's.
Look,
there's an elite world class athletes in
Jujitsu that don't.
Do you know if the world champion got
high or not?
Well,
I know a lot.
I do,
but I know a lot of them do.
A lot of world champions do.
I know a lot of like real multiple time
world champion.
They're marijuana users.
Yeah.
How about world champions that don't get
high?
There's a lot of those to see.
What happens with marijuana is increased
sensitivity that a lot of people talk
about.
They call it paranoia because there's a
lot of things that people put blinders
on their life.
A lot of people aren't aware,
and I'm sure because of your hunting,
you're spending time in the woods.
You're soaking in all the variables.
The sound when I'm a radar there.
Right.
You're aware there's a lot of people
that go through life like this.
No.
They go through life like they're
looking through a toilet paper roll
there in the left lane right now.
Yeah.
They're not.
They're not using their blinkers and
those people,
when they smoke marijuana,
they freak out.
They get paranoid because what's
happening is the marijuana increases.
Your sensitivity makes you aware of all
these variables and a lot of people
consider that paranoia.
He started freaking out about all these
variables.
You start thinking about your mortality
and instead of embracing this time as a
magical moment,
instead of being in this moment,
you just start getting overwhelmed and
you feel your own heartbeat and you
start freaking.
Now this all the time,
it's without anything.
It's an entheogenic.
It brings you closer to whatever you are
not encumbered by your ego.
I will
admit in escapable that everything
affects everyone differently.
Yes,
but once you make it widespread,
I mean,
I've studied the results of legalization
for recreational use in Colorado and how
the highway fatalities and accidents
have increased,
but you know what else has increased the
population in proportion,
so it causes breeding.
Thousands is more people there.
More people are there,
so you having more accidents there.
The problem is is a boom of population
also a boom in the economy of boom,
in the real estate.
Real estate's taking off.
Yeah,
there's a lot of losers there too,
because a lot of hacky sack playing
dirty,
stinky hippies that are wandering around
with no shoes on.
You're going to get those.
You know,
if you have an opening welcome society
that's.
That doesn't lock those people up,
you're going to have those as a part of
freedom.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Losers are a part of this safe world
that our kids are allowed to wander too.
We want the world to be safe,
so sometimes things are too safe.
You nerve the edges and you get a bunch
of people that are used to hitting their
heads on things and they're not worried
about it.
You're going to have these losers,
but it doesn't mean that everybody who
does,
it's a loser.
I know a lot of CEO's of big
corporations that have responsibilities
and they liked to smoke a little pot.
I get,
I get punched back off and on facebook.
I'm a successful guy,
run my family.
I'm a good dad.
I'm a good hunter and I'm a.
I'm a trump supporter and I get high.
Oh God bless you.
I just,
I don't watch a babysitting my kids
while you're high.
Yeah,
but it's discipline.
Discipline is the thing that fucks
people up and the lack of this lack of
the lack of discipline and I think
that's with everything and could be with
sex.
It could be with gambling,
it could be with extreme risky
behaviors.
People could just get,
get real nutty and get carried away with
things and sometimes those things are
just a big distraction for the lack of
discipline they have in pursuing their
own goals in life.
I think that that is the real high in
life.
The real high end life is pursuing
difficult things.
Ratification,
yes,
getting good at them and then
accomplishing your goals.
There's A.
There's a high to that that's.
You can't find that in pills.
It doesn't exist in the needle.
That high is a high of discipline and
determination and focus in learning,
but there's so much weakness out there,
especially in a society that has been
spoiled for so long and you get a trophy
if you don't even show up and you can't
hurt people's feelings and bullied,
get bullied and you're crying.
Should fight and back,
I mean there's so many manifestation of
a cultural deprivation that runs a muck
in our society that my fear is nice.
Studied all these mass shootings.
Joe,
the Virginia Tech shooter high.
Well,
they're all buying high.
Yeah,
but they're all on SSRI.
Yes.
They're all on pills and
pharmaceuticals.
Almost all of them are on the PROZAC and
their parents or all of them are
chemical covering up a kid that shows
enthusiasm.
It's called an attention disorder now.
I mean,
if they had that back when I was growing
up,
I had ended up playing.
I don't know,
I ended up being nosy,
but the problem is the word drugs,
like you and I are drinking coffee.
We're on drugs right now.
We're on caffeine.
This is a drug.
There's some drugs that if used
responsibly or.
Okay.
A glass of wine with dinner is a
drought.
Understood.
It's a mild drug,
a little tiny Toke
for sex with the Mrs. That's a little
drug and it makes you see I've never
smoked because I can't smoke.
I get in,
when I shoot my machine guns,
all I do is chew on a Cuban.
I don't really smoke it well.
You can get a little buzz.
Just love it.
Seems to go with brash rainbows.
When I had that tight,
tight,
tight site,
I was way faster than my best.
My best morning
with my m four a,
it's a,
it's a [inaudible] carbon.
And I got a pof upper to piston driven.
So instead of 600 plus rounds,
minutes over 700 rounds a minute and my
$600 to sit,
whether it is way too low,
but they actually had the original,
um,
uh,
Thompson's.
We're 900 rounds a minute and nobody
including sargent rock could control
that.
So they backed it down to 600,
but that's 45 and it's got a whole lot
of lift.
My two to three m for my best morning.
And this is how uncle Ted parties,
Apache helicopter M,
four bags of Ammo,
469 hogs.
One day we played videos that you and
pig phillips.
No ridiculous that,
that is every wild.
But that the pig problem is the one that
throws in the face of vegans.
That's a weird one because you,
you got to do something about those
animals because they're going to destroy
your food.
Sure.
They're going to eat every when we kill
pigs like that in such mass numbers from
helicopters with machine guns,
we're literally saving the environment,
feeding a lot of people.
We the pork that we process.
Thousands and thousands of people get
this pure organic port and it's
delicious.
The best.
The wild pork without white fat,
dark meat handy.
So.
So we're saving the environment from the
pig destruction.
We're saving agriculture.
I eat food production from the pig
destruction.
We're saving tax dollars from hiring
sharp shooters.
We're saving all wildlife because the
alternative would have been a
indiscriminate poisoning campaign and
recreating a huge new industry of
helicopter hog hunting.
When?
When,
when,
when will copter Haagan serious party
time USA.
And guess who passed that law?
You did.
Thank you very much.
Again,
me and Chris Cole back.
We were hunting and we weren't allowed
to pay the helicopter pilot by law.
You couldn't be a for profit outfit
unless the government paid him,
which was so,
so and Texas,
so Kris Kobach,
who was the secretary of state and
Kansas and was running for governor and
should be governor of Kansas.
He's a constitutional master and he.
He took the current a pig hunting law
firm,
helicopters that was government
controlled.
No,
no citizens,
no commercial value whatsoever.
He rewrote it.
We gave it to then Attorney General Greg
Abbott and Governor Perry at the time
and we said,
this is insane.
This can't be Texas where you get to
hunt the pigs on our land,
but we can't,
so literally within a week or two,
they passed the law where it became a
commercial outfit where we,
the people can hunt the pigs out of
helicopters and it's become a huge
success.
It's really knocked the shit out of this
dangerous pig population in those areas
where land owners allow it and give
authorization and if so much fun,
it's stupid.
Well,
that's what people need to realize.
You re,
there's no way to get to them
in certain circumstances.
There accessible.
There are millions and millions of wild
pigs.
They have three,
four litters a year,
and there's no way to take care of them
naturally.
Unless you gonna let hundreds of
thousands of wolves loose in Texas.
I'd really don't sit down with them from
the helicopters.
Yeah,
I mean how.
I mean,
that's what they do in Alaska when they
decimate the care enough to they.
There's no other way to control these
pigs other than God bless you,
joy.
Not many people know that.
They don't know that and it's a.
it's a real problem when you talk to
people were animal rights activists,
like,
how do you propose to fix this?
That will like,
well,
you know,
they shouldn't be here in the first
place.
They're an invasive species that people,
Bro.
That's fine.
You're right.
But they're handing over in the 17
hundreds.
So what do we do?
So.
So arrest.
Captain Cook.
Yeah,
exactly.
Arrest William Randolph hearst because
he released a bunch of them are in
northern California.
That's where it starts to hone.
Ranch came from those pigs down and they
worked their way down and they're
awesome.
They're delicious,
delicious.
The best pork in the world,
people who eat normal pork have no idea
what real pork tastes like.
I smoked some for a friend of mine.
This is insane.
I'm like this.
He's like,
this is insane.
Put it over.
A good coal will coles.
Yeah,
it's candy.
Brian did for a few days and here's a
little trick for you.
I.
I'm a vernors Ginger Rail Guide,
Detroit brewed bottled and Ginger,
Detroit vernors.
It's the only ginger ale without ginger
from the fortunate is full of fructose,
so I don't drink it anymore,
but you can cook with it.
Next time you Brian,
a slab of pork,
put in a good olive oil and all the
seasons you like,
but also can have vernors ginger ale
because it's got real ginger and just
enough sugar in it to affect it and soak
that overnight in a glass dish.
Covered up in a cool like a refrigerator
and then put that sum bitch on some hot
orange,
Kohl's.
I don't care.
Apple,
Cherry,
Mesquite,
Hickory,
whatever.
You got old.
Doesn't matter and let that song bitch
just singed on the outside.
It's.
It's food,
sex.
It's your in a wreck,
your palate erection.
You get a culinary boner.
It's so delicious.
That's what we eat at home.
That's how we eat.
That's why I'm like this.
Do you ever use a pellet grill?
I haven't,
no.
My,
um,
my ranch manager,
Chris has got one.
Um,
and he used a big fan of those things
because it's real wood,
right?
It's just compressed wood shots they
take,
like from making this table should take
that sawdust to compress it down.
But I have all this timber we have at
our properties.
I like cutting down dead trees and
making my own firewood.
Is that what you do?
You Cook over here?
Well,
there's a,
there's something to that,
right?
Yep.
It's the real mccoy.
Yeah.
My,
my taste buds are as sacred as my dick.
I mean,
I want to make sure I treat my taste
buds really good.
I consider my life to be like one big
six foot two,
220 pound purple rim.
Dick.
I'm susceptible to all influences and
stimuli and that's where I get this
passion in this happiness everyday.
Spoiled rotten.
I get to hunt everywhere,
that's what's crazy and I get to rock my
balls off every year.
So I'm the lucky one in your yard.
You essentially leave your house.
My swamp in Michigan,
I have to close the door quietly because
I have tree stands really close to the
cabin and it's.
The swamp is,
it's a miracle.
It's just,
I think God loves me more than he loves
you because you created this place just
for me and it.
It's a,
it's a glacier cut marsh swamp.
Phen phen is no fen fen.
It's a very unique wetland habitat
that's a cross between a marsh and swamp
and a bog and it's the,
uh,
the uh,
habitat that produces the Mitchells
cetera butterfly environment,
which is the Christmas tree from and on
my Michigan Fan,
I have the healthiest productivity of
the endangered species,
Christmas tree fern and Mitchell's
setter.
Butterfly according to the biologists
and the botanists that visit there every
year from universities because I killed
lots of critters that would otherwise
denude those touchy for her wild
vegetations.
And that's why a hundred every day up
there,
I coons and possums and skunks and
beavers,
mink and muskrats and pheasants up the
as I.
I'm the only ground in southern Michigan
that has pheasants because I wage war
environments.
You cannot hurt vomit populations.
In fact they are drastically under
harvested.
But on mine,
I killed so many egg rate environments
that I have the best biodiversity of
all,
including the endangered Mitchell
Saturday butterfly and Christmas tree
fern because I'm a steward who actually
walks the wild ground,
unlike a bureaucrat who looks at the
computer screen and is dnr office and
makes an assumption of what the model
might indicate instead of what the
actual wild ground will show you if you
get the fuck off your chair and go walk
that say,
well,
that's a big criticism to people or from
people that,
uh,
especially like people in bc that are
now a part of that grizzly bear band,
unbelievably dishonest.
They're getting people that live in the
city that don't have any interaction
with these animals and that these
animals are trouble.
There's a lot of them.
They're not there can only you can eat
them too,
by the way.
I think their stakes bear backstraps
candy,
especially in the spring if they're
eating berries and the grass,
but the perception is that what you're
doing is trophy hunting,
that you know you're eating,
you're shooting something you don't plan
on eating,
just to put a hand on you because you're
a cruel person.
How dishonest can you be?
Well,
they're not talking to the people that
are in the forest,
the actual people that are on the
ground,
and that's,
that's a real part of the problem is
that these laws get passed by these
people that have no interaction with
this actual environment.
It's like people who live in a drought
voting on what's going on in your flood.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like the people in Detroit voting
on wolves in the upper peninsula.
If you don't
live with bull with the wolves,
you don't get say so.
You need to respect the people who live
with the wolves and wolves.
Don't buy licenses.
Wolves don't buy permits.
Wolves don't pay fees.
Wolves don't have bag limits.
Wolves don't have seasons.
They just like to kill stuff and if you
have too many wolves,
nobody spending money on deer license or
bear license or small game hunting,
and the upper peninsula of Michigan has
been abandoned by a bunch of politically
correct ignorant city jerks who think
they have to save the endangered wolf.
I want wolves in Michigan,
but not to the detriment of wildlife
that actually pays for the game
department to manage it for a sustained
yield productivity,
Duh.
But that's the thing we're talking about
here,
right?
Like wildlife management,
like this idea that you have to manage
the population of pigs.
You also have to like what you're doing
in your place in Michigan.
You're managing this wildlife to the
ultimate diversity that if you don't
have to deal with walls and if you don't
yet higher tax paid sharp shooters that
have no respect for the animals at all.
They're just doing a job of killing
stuff,
which is what they do in California with
the mountain lions.
Unbelievably irresponsible.
And here's a challenge and a
condemnation for the California fish and
game society.
The cod fish and game anymore,
they call it fish,
fish and wildlife.
Because of that,
how can you go to work everyday,
violating your oath to wildlife science?
How can you force the mountain lion and
the black bear and California into the
liability column as a game warden,
as a person dedicated to conservation,
how can you violate your wise use oath
and turn them out in line and the black
bear into a liability because some dirt
bag in San Francisco think it's unfair
to use hounds or bait for bear and then
you have to go in and shoot black bears
with tax dollars and buried them in a
hole in the ground instead of a family
recreational,
a resource that you buy licenses and
fees and permits and guides and
outfitters,
hotels,
food lodging,
grocery supplies,
butcher's ice,
taxidermists.
None of that happens because the some
liar has forced the wildlife manager,
wildlife mismanagement of California to
ban mountain lion hunting.
While you continue to kill them as
damage control,
instead of manage them as quality
control.
Shame on the California wildlife
officers.
Shame on you for not blowing the
whistle.
It's like,
call me at the FBI,
how dare you walk into that building
that says j Edgar Hoover over the top
and not feel a sense of guilt because j
Edgar Hoover was one of the biggest
criminal punks that ever walked this
earth and now call me is following in
his footsteps and I challenged my FBI
buddies.
How did you go all these years without
blowing the whistles on the corruption,
the power abuse and the criminality by
your so
called leaders?
I don't know enough about pussy to
comment,
but I don't know enough about what you
did do.
I do know because he's a liar and he's.
He's a.
he's a perjurer and he's a felon and he
had a.
I'm really angry because I worked with
the FBI.
I've had to rely on these guys to cover
my back on on raids and they're great
warriors and they look the other way
because they're saving their pensions
and instead of blowing the whistles on
there,
corrupt criminal leaders.
Damn them.
Well,
I don't know how that relates to
mountain lions.
Like to bring it all back.
Corruption is corruption.
Same thing,
but I was saying I don't think it's
corruption here,
wildlife officers that I don't think
they're getting this conversation.
I think there is some that they're
trying to preserve their jobs.
They don't want to stick their neck out
with a very liberal government,
but you know,
I think that there's.
There's a real problem with education
that this conversation doesn't happen in
most circles.
This understanding of balance,
of nature of that you really do have to
manage the wardens.
They know what they studied,
they got degrees in it and they defy it
and it's good.
Good about permits.
After the mountain lion is destroyed,
millions of dollars worth of livestock
and pets and it scared the shit out of
people and killed people.
Then they kill them,
kill them before they just do the depth.
Supposed to be quality control,
not damage control.
They know the system,
they've abandoned it and they've gone
the political correct denial route and
said that the mountain lions are not
game animals.
That is a lie.
So the California Game Department are
Liars,
period.
With the idea of the mount lines on a
game.
Animal comes from people that have never
eaten one.
Yeah,
the estimate backstrap.
Most people don't know.
I've never eaten one,
but I know people that have he
delicious,
which beautiful p.
You hear,
you tell that to people and they go,
wait a minute.
What I can bear.
A lot of people don't think eat bears.
Eat Berries.
You dirt bag.
Who doesn't know this?
Wake up.
A lot of people don't know they're
idiots.
I've had conversations with people
because I'm 100 bears that no one has
gotten more mad at me at anything I've
ever done.
Then when I killed a bear,
good,
good for you.
That you pissed.
If you're not pissing off the assholes,
you're an asshole,
but it's people that don't understand
what a bear is not around.
Then they don't understand.
I recommend shut the fuck up.
Go do a little research and come back
when you have some knowledge.
Until then,
suck my dick.
No,
it's better to just explain to them what
it is and I see it over and over again.
Refused.
They refused to listen.
Yeah,
they.
They liked their ignorance.
They go to maniacal levels to protect
their ignorance because it feels good
because it's booboo.
It's really a tune.
I respect animals,
so I'm going to reduce them to the level
of a cartoon.
What's also weird too,
because there was a deprivation permit
that was issued for a mountain lion in
Malibu because it was killing the got to
this Alpaca farm and just went fucking
crazy.
Like 10 Alpaca and Alpaca.
Yum.
Yeah,
just fucked.
I didn't even eat.
I'm just fucked him off.
They laid lines to kill.
I'm a
big fan,
so a deprivation depredation permit was
issued so this.
They destroyed a bunch of livestock so
this lady could kill this cat that had
been really qualified,
so she was going to hire somebody,
but then she got all these death
threats,
which is hilarious,
but here's the thing,
people say they love animals.
Well,
you obviously don't love these Alpine
lions coming in and fucking killing them
all the time.
The way they die,
a slow death because the lion just bites
them and let them bleed to death and
flop around for a couple hours and then
goes to the one that's next to it.
He's just trying to get away.
It's the ignorance is staggering and
that's why I continue to fight it.
It's convenient,
right?
It's like,
we love animals.
We don't want to kill this mountain
lion.
Okay,
well if you love animals,
you'll let them kill this one mountain
line that's obviously targeting these
pets because this is not hunting.
By the way.
You know why they're mountain lion is
targeting the pests because there's too
many mountain lions and the dominant
males have run all the other mountain
lions out of ideal habitat into your
neighborhood because you didn't harvest
the surplus.
Now the surplus is coming into your
home.
Now it's a liability because you were
too stupid to keep it in the asset
column.
It's absolutely sinful.
People have accomplished.
They have a pond over it to hone ranch.
They have a game camera,
the trail camera on that pond.
They got 16 different mountain lions are
in that camera.
Then they're not allowed to do damn
thing and it's hard to find deer.
It's hard to find deer here.
It's like it's nothing.
I mean,
the one thing is good people aren't
dying in car accidents with deer,
but if you see a deer in California,
it's.
It's pretty rare,
but again,
there's plenty of cattle.
I fly over California.
I Love California,
man.
My blood brothers live out here.
We're having the greatest conscience.
My late last night in San Juan
Capistrano firestorm tonight,
tomorrow night we're in Pasadena,
and then we'd go to a Gore hills.
Clear Rita.
Yeah,
and then we go to big bear and then we
go to reno and we'd go to Iowa and Ohio
and Pennsylvania and know we're all over
the country and I fly in a little plane
over the country and it's God's country.
It's wildlife habitat.
It eternally all across this country and
California is one of the most beautiful
wilderness states in the world,
and because mountain lions have been
irresponsibly mismanaged,
now you have a destruction of the
wildlife in the deer category and those
small game and other game because the
mountain lions are in the liability
column.
If you reduce the mountain lion numbers,
then hunters will pay for the deer
licenses which pay for the game
departments in the scientists to manage
the wildlife sea.
We have balanced California is him
balanced.
It's out of balance because of the lie
of the animal rights that have effect
how the wildlife officers of this
country,
except that bullshit is just a crime.
They should stand up and go your wrong.
This is a renewable wildlife research
resource and we're going to have a
season on it because now we're killing
them as damage control.
They're still dying.
We're killing them.
We're taking millions of dollars to
compensate the Lama and the
Alpaca and the cattle and the sheep and
the goat and the horse.
We're millions of dollars compensating
and then we're going to kill the lion
and bury it.
No,
you don't get to eat it.
No.
You don't get to spend any money and
provide game department,
finances.
No.
You don't get to go to hotels and travel
and food and lodging and supplies and
sporting goods and taxidermist.
You don't get to increase the economy of
the entire area because of one mountain
lion hunt.
We're going to take your tax dollars and
compensate all the dead livestock and
then we're going to hire a guy to kill
the mountain lion Joe.
Dig a hole,
which by the we're going to take your
tax dollars to hire a guy with a front
loader,
dig a hole and bury.
Don't put this magnificent animal public
perception.
It's because of the average person like
you saved precept chunks.
I have dogs.
It's not perception.
It's ignorance and it's
this perception that does come from
ignorance is that we love animals.
Like I have a dog.
You have dogs.
I've lived for my.
Yeah,
I have three dogs.
We love dogs.
Can't live without them.
You go home,
you pat them.
People that don't have any interaction
whatsoever with wildlife.
Think of animals like they think of
their dog.
I don't want anything to document and
then you hear about a mountain lion
like,
oh,
why would you kill them?
Outlined mind you're being cruel,
like you would only kill them.
Outline if you're one of those dickless
assholes and once I go to Africa and
shoot a line and the head mounted on
your wall just because.
But this is the thought process behind
it and there's no pushback because the
public speaks and then I pushed back in
the attack.
They attack you bring it on,
bring it up because ignorance bounces
off of me.
Like personal hygiene from Michael
Moore.
It just has no impact whatsoever.
I think he washes you don't think God
what a.
What a swine.
He.
That's a subhuman Mongrel.
If I ever saw I met him,
he was in this guy.
He's a prick.
He's a liar.
What do you think?
He's a scam artist.
Like gun control.
Well,
how about the fact that he put together
that move,
that so documented that Hollywood
actually gave them an award and he
copied and pasted out of sequence the
attack on the grid.
Charlton Heston claiming he was somehow
responsible for the little child killing
herself with you're paroled felon,
father's gun,
and they put it out of sequence and
attributed.
Charlton Heston defending such
irresponsible gun ownership.
Michael Moore is a line,
cruel,
stoned punk,
as he stoned constantly all day.
All the time.
I think he used the suppositories.
I don't know him.
I do and I.
He's a punk.
Has He ever had a conversation?
Got.
Yeah.
I was on his TV show and I was
responsible for ending his TV show
because he tried to fuck with me and I
don't know if you'd noticed you,
but I'm unfuckable you.
Fuck with me.
I'll eat your family tree and shit.
Saw dust into your face.
Ask Pierce Morgan.
That seems like I saw your compensation.
Not even close.
I was arm wrestling a torso.
Well,
the Pierce Morgan.
The problem is he didn't understand the
facts.
When you talk about gun violence,
he didn't understand how much of
guidelines.
In fact he knew them.
He avoided
him.
That's true.
Absolutely.
Plus,
we explain what we're talking about
because when you say the numbers of gun
violence,
a giant percentage of murder suicide,
a giant percentage of them are cops
killing bad guys and citizens defendant.
So all of those are out of the.
And then accidental gun deaths may have
summarized it for you.
So Pierce Morgan fancies himself a
cookie,
rather woody limey usually got the
accent and everything.
It's funny little Matt actually an
accent.
It's an impediment.
But,
uh,
he came out and of course he's going to
take on the motor city madman.
I mean this guy is going to be easy
pickins.
He actually wrote Wango tango be all
intellectually this thing you're doing,
that's the limey.
You've got manufactured confidence based
on nothing except an ego that has no
foundation.
In fact.
So Pierce Morgan,
the CNN exec,
so when it's put Pierce Morgan on the
Motor City Madman in a gun store to the
first time you didn't see the first one
at the CNN officers,
that's the best thing.
Both of them,
that's the best one.
And so they think I'm a dirt bag and in
a goof ball because I not only wrote
Wang Dang sweet poon Tang,
I meant it,
but when they take me on they don't
realize I never went to college because
I was too busy learning shit.
And if you take me on,
on any subject that I am even slightly
aware of,
I will fuck you up because I've studied
this stuff.
I've lived this stuff.
I've been with guns since I could walk.
I have had universal unlimited access to
fire power my whole life,
both in a recreational,
a disciplined,
a law enforcement military training,
and just a family plinking competition.
So when every considerable,
a imaginable gun use,
I've been 68 years of it.
Um,
so they sick Pierce Morgan Ami to teach
me a lesson about how irresponsible gun
owners are and that if we could just ban
guns,
that all the violence would end.
And of course,
if you haven't seen it,
you got to google it because it was his.
What's his take?
Well,
I've,
I almost fixed them,
um,
because I so overwhelmed them with
evidence that they finally research and
realized that every word out of my mouth
was absolutely indisputable.
What was most compelling that you were
saying to him?
I'll,
I'll summarize it this way.
Like I did the pierce.
The anti gunners have their dream.
It exists.
It existed in a Paris where all those
people were shot with coalition of
coughs,
coalition to costs were banned.
They have their dream.
Pierce morgans dream exists.
It's called a gun free zone.
Virginia Tech,
Columbine,
Sandy Hook,
Aurora,
Parklin every instance where the most
innocent lives have been,
had been a Nancy Pelosi,
maxine waters,
Eric holder,
Hillary Clinton,
Barack Obama's dream.
Their dream is a gun free zone,
but we're free.
People are forced,
forced into unarmed helplessness where
the most innocent lives are lost and
that dream has produced more carnage and
destroyed lives than anything in the
world compared to the NRA convention
where you have the highest incidence of
gun ownership or opening day of deer
season in Michigan where you have 100
percent gun ownership and access where
nobody gets hurt.
So if you know that your dream is a gun
free zone and that's where the most
innocent lives are lost,
what kind of demonic dirt bag would
actually want more?
Well,
let me stop.
Let me stop being kids position or
anybody's position.
On the other side.
You would say the real gun free zone
would be no one having access to the gun
that killed those people in the gun free
zone,
a gun free zone,
and the real and the real answer to
drownings in America would be the band
water.
And you work on banning water.
I'll work on banning guns and we'll
touch base every few weeks and see how
you can not banned.
You cannot eliminate guns.
Finland,
you cannot eliminate guns.
Uh,
Alberta Canada,
where the guy who came into the
University of shot everybody up.
It's impossible.
So what you do,
instead of thinking you could ban water,
learn to swim and watch your children by
the pool.
Call me weird.
But the way to handle violence is to
carry a gun practice with it.
And when someone brings lethal force
against you,
shoot the motherfucker.
But people are very uncomfortable with
the idea of any society,
comfortable babies.
Sorry,
you're uncomfortable that go ahead and
bend over and die.
But you know what I'm saying.
I know what you're saying,
but wouldn't it be better if there
weren't any concern that the.
The,
the idea is to somehow enter the
takeaway,
the concern of people being shot
randomly by some psycho that you've got
to figure out if you get all the guns
away,
how do you get all the guns away?
Oh No.
I don't know.
But this is what I'm saying is that you
don't know.
So let's just start.
If they're not,
if it's not that,
then everybody's got guns to shoot.
Nobody.
Everybody will not have guns.
Some people have guns.
Some people here.
I studied San Bernardino.
I studied at Aurora.
I started at Virginia Tech.
I studied columbine.
I studied sandy hook.
I studied them all.
Do you know joe and everybody better
write this down because I'm the only guy
that will tell you this.
I've studied the cadence,
the bullet manufacturers,
the rate of fire,
the movement of the purpose,
and the movement of the victims.
In every instance,
including in Connecticut,
including Aurora,
including San Bernardino,
right here,
there were American citizens who would
have had a gun on their person if they
were allowed to and they could have been
a meaningful force to at least reduce,
if not terminate the violent murderous
threat,
but by law we have been so dumbed down
and so forced against our natural
survival instinct to have a tool on our
belt that in every instance where the
most innocent lives were slaughtered,
those people that would have intervened
with a firearm.
Not many of them,
but there was a janitor.
There was a couple of guys in the
office.
They had concealed weapons permits,
but they weren't allowed to have in that
building.
In Virginia Tech,
there were guys that had concealed
weapons permits,
but they weren't allowed to have them
there in Aurora,
Colorado.
Are you kidding me?
All kinds of people would have had guns.
They could have returned fire,
but they were forced into unarmed
helplessness.
Here,
here's the gun debate.
In it's con,
irrefutable conclusion,
if you are forced into unarmed
helplessness,
you are unarmed and helpless.
What a horrible,
irresponsible,
suicidal condition that in.
I'm just a guitar player,
Joe.
I've never been on armed since I
graduated from high school.
I've always had a hanky and a pocket
full of guitar picks and a pocket knife
and a belt knife and built tool and a
pistol and some extra bullets.
I just have them everywhere I go.
I've never been on armed.
I find it.
How do you travel around?
I improvise,
adapt,
and overcome.
I luckily I helped pass house resolution
to 18,
which means all sworn law enforcement
officer allowed to carry a gun
nationwide.
I've been a sheriff deputy since 1984
and my credentials allow me to carry a
gun everywhere I go and I carry a gun
everywhere I go.
In fact,
even in England,
uh,
American law enforcement are allowed to
carry guns and I carry a gun over there.
It's just a tool.
If somebody comes up and we carry a gun
in England.
Yeah,
eat some dirt bag.
Comes at me with a spike in the board.
I'll just shoot them,
but why not?
What's plan b?
No,
I.
I agree that it's better to be better,
to have it and not need it than to need
it and not to have been.
The thing that we would all like to have
is no school shootings,
no mass shootings,
no reward,
no columbine,
no.
So how do you stop that?
Do you think you stopped that with more
guns?
Where do you think you stopped that with
mental health education,
figuring out how to get people off of
pills,
figuring out how to keep people from
living despondent lives where they want
to just tear it all down and shoot
everybody in her hurt a bunch of people.
Well,
here we are.
That's the route,
right?
Sure.
Here we are.
We are
2018 so we can't go back in history in
find the goofball from Virginia Tech and
what motivated him.
We can't go back there because we have
failed as a society to take care of
people or respond with any sense of
responsibility or effectiveness to the
glaring
danger signs most outrageously in
Parkland where the guy called the cops
42 times,
called the FBI three times that guys
going to shoot up the school.
Okay.
We'll make a note of that.
No,
the guy's going to shoot up the school.
Okay.
We'll make a note of that.
The guy is bringing a gun to school to
shoot people.
Here's his manifesto.
We've made a note of that.
What are you kidding me?
So now if we go for them to do something
until someone does something which not.
No,
no,
it's not.
I don't think it's a failure of law
enforcement.
I had put matter.
It's just a shooting two hours ago.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Another one,
five people are dead and multiple people
are.
Where?
Annapolis,
Maryland at a Oh,
Maryland.
Where no one's allowed to have a gun by
the way.
Maryland to a newsroom and shot a bunch
of reporters.
How much cheese?
A bit.
It was a gun free zone.
Annapolis newsroom shooting leaves.
Five people dead.
Suspect in custody.
A newsroom.
Yeah.
Well,
there's my point.
So I made a newsroom and I'm ready to
rock.
I'd rather be sitting where you are,
but I figured you got me covered.
My point is is that the cat is already
out of the bag,
but
it's not too late.
Columbine guys,
glaring signals,
red alarms going off over Virginia Tech
Guy.
Red Alarms going off for years,
but the columbine thing is a difficult
one because it really hadn't happened
before that no one expected it,
but the parents walked through the
garage for three years where the bomb
making materials were on the table.
Yeah,
they weren't.
The best parents guys were like zombies.
These guys were like doper freaks from
Bonzai Zulu land maniacs.
Well,
he's just.
He's just different.
No,
he's not.
He's freaky.
We need to sit down with this guy and
get him some healthy.
Aurora guy told his psychiatrist.
My goal is to shoot as many people as
possible and the psychiatrist didn't say
anything really.
It's on record.
He said it in numerous visits with his
psychiatrist that he had threatened his
golden life was to kill as many people
as possible and he's now got his new ar
15 to do it with and the psychiatrist
didn't say anything.
I've studied this stuff.
We need to not only see something,
say something,
we're missing the part,
the final part do something when this
kind of abberant threatening violent red
alarm behaviors going off.
Inter veen sit down with this kid at the
first instance when your kid comes home,
all glassy eyed and goofy and
incommunicable and showing weird signs
like the sandy hook guide he had all his
life and the Aurora guy did all his life
and the Parkland guys.
I'm being all staring like a.
When blinken a sandstorm,
somebody go.
I know I would.
I mean in my life with her as musicians
or family members are going,
are you going to write what is going on?
You look like you're going to shit
yourself,
man.
Are you okay?
Didn't have that conversation with
somebody like the psychiatrist did to
the Aurora shooter.
Didn't mean how do you fix these people?
I mean,
what you're saying is if you have no gun
free zones and people allowed to have
guns,
at least they'll have an ability to
defend themselves.
I agree with you.
I agree with you on that,
but how do you stop it from happening in
the first place?
The anti gun people say the way to stop
it is to have no guns available to
civilians that can do things virtually
impossible.
A porsche.
So what we're dealing with just
pragmatically,
when you look at 300 million people and
probably 400 million guns,
but you haven't counted mine yet.
I mean,
how many guns for every guy like you
that has hundreds of guns,
you know,
almost everybody I know has hundreds of
guns.
He just not like a man.
I got hundreds of arrows.
I have four.
I have thousands of guitars.
Um,
we need to be a more assertive,
aggressive,
compassionate,
aware society.
And when we see these glaring
indicators,
we're never going to stop it all.
There's always going to be a evil in our
lives and you can't stop it.
Hence,
you should be armed and prepared.
And if you're not comfortably being
armed,
by all means,
don't be.
If you don't want to.
Like I saw the debate bill marcy or why
you can't expect every teacher to have a
gun.
I go,
who's ever recommended that?
That's what the anti gun people always
go.
Why should have everybody should have a
machine gun just shooting everything.
Yeah.
That's a pretty good.
That quote for quote what I recommended.
They go to the deep end every time where
they're trying to make fun,
they try to make fun of the proposition.
Unbelievable.
Should be armed against killers.
There are people I know everywhere.
Teachers,
grocery store,
baggers,
a name,
a walk of life.
My Weldon Buddy,
my mechanic,
my dentist,
my doctor,
Dr. strapped.
Yes.
I mean they just.
They're pragmatists,
they're utilitarian.
They're self sufficient.
What?
When did that become an desirable to be
self sufficient and capable?
I think that's the problem.
I think what we're saying is that we
have such a gun problem.
There's so many people in so many guns
that people just want to somehow or
another they do finish the numbers.
Joe,
we do not have a gun problem.
When I was growing up,
we had guns in school during the season.
Rifles,
shotguns were brought and put in your
lockers.
There was unlimited ubiquitous access to
firepower throughout my youth.
No school shootings,
something else has happened and it has
to do with big farm in the dis,
the irresponsible knee jerk,
a bandage on a gaping wound of a,
of a child showing up at each childlike
behavior.
And all of a sudden they PROZAC,
um,
in a Ritalin.
Them,
this stuff turns into a Zombie.
My dear,
dear blood brother,
cliff Davis,
the greatest
drummer on the planet listened to what
he did on the Ted nugent album and the
cat scratch fever album in the free for
all album.
And the weekend,
I mean this guy was a god of musicality.
He became depressed and was prescribed.
And the incidents of people being
prescribed a mood controllers in emotion
controllers and depression controllers.
The incidents in the consistency with
which they attempt to go cold Turkey and
kill themselves.
You,
your brain becomes changed.
It becomes altered.
Your logic meter is off duty with this
pharmaceuticals in your system.
Cliff came home,
decided to get off the PROZAC,
walked out into the yard screaming,
thrown his clothes out the window and
shot himself in the head and Aurora guy,
all the.
They're all on something.
It's true.
It's at and mothers and fathers out
there.
Discipline is the answer,
not pharmaceuticals.
Conversation is the answer.
Probing parenting is the answer would.
Like I said,
when I was growing up,
we had a cuckoo's business,
we had a eloise and people showed
dangerous and an in an antisocial
behavior.
You intervened and you put them in an
institution and even that was a mistake
because there was always a chemical
response instead of a,
a compassionate response to chemical to
some people do or fucked in the head.
Yes,
you do have to do something.
Absolutely,
but there is the argument that there's a
lot of people that take these
pharmaceuticals and they have no violent
outbursts,
which I agree with too,
but the people that do have violent
outbursts are almost universally on
something universe.
Yeah.
If you look at the numbers,
and I've said this many times that I
don't think we have a gun problem,
I think we have a mental health problem
disguised as a gun problem.
Absolutely,
because whether it's someone driving a
truck into a crowd of people,
that's the same thing.
Do you think,
do you think after 42 calls to the
sheriff's department threatening to
shoot the school and three to the FBI,
do you think the Parkland shooters
should've been visited a little earlier
than after 42 and three calls of
threatening to shoot up the school?
Do you think the authorities should have
the right to go visit this kid,
get the guns out of there,
don't you think when you say,
I am going to shoot up the school in my
world,
that would be good enough to disqualify
that person from owning a gun?
I agree with you.
I don't know what the circumstances were
with the Parkland kid and I do.
I know that the FBI did visit him on one
occasion.
Not good enough.
You.
I don't know what they there.
It's not like he was peeing on the Alamo
and just being a dirt bag.
He was threatening to kill as many
people as possible.
That to me is enough information to
disarm the guy and probably
institutionalized Murray's and take him
in for review to a psychiatric ward.
At that point,
you can't say,
I'm going to kill people yet.
Can't say that.
Are you comfortable with a world where
there's so much gun violence that
everybody just has to be strapped or.
No Way?
The last thing I.
I've said it 100 times.
I'm going to say it again on the Joe
Rogan podcast.
Write it down.
I do not want everyone to carry a gun.
I do not want everyone to own a gun.
I don't want everyone to hunt.
I don't want everyone to have an 850
horsepower Ford Bronco.
I don't want everyone to go on the Joe
Rogan podcast.
There is a time and place for
individuality and individual choices and
many people will always be
uncomfortable.
You know,
taken a hook out of a fish's lip,
so don't go fishing and if you don't
feel comfortable around guns,
by all means,
just don't have one,
but those of us that have a hint of
warrior instinct and rugged boy scout
being prepared,
desire,
don't disarm us,
we're your best friend with and they're
everywhere.
They're those teachers in all these
school shootings that were teachers that
would have had a gun but they were
forbidden to and there are instances,
and this is something that people that
are anti gun don't like to talk about,
but there are instances where trained
shooters have stopped.
Mass shootings have stopped someone
killing people.
It's theirs and let me come in on the
train while I.
As long as they get training,
let's let's,
let's squash that myth.
Big Old fat Jewish lady in New York City
back in the sixties.
She was robbed at gunpoint at knife
point over and over again.
Remember when they had like 2000 murders
a year in man.
It just runaway mayhem.
She was getting upset.
She wanted to get a pistol and she went
to the police station.
I need to get permanent.
Well,
I'm sorry we don't give permission,
but I had been robbed all these times.
I'm scared.
He comes back all the time.
A guy had his good points gun once my
money.
I'm sorry,
you can't have a gun.
So she was frustrated.
This was a documented case and so she
went to uncle Joe and uncle John.
I'm scared.
I need a gun.
Guy Keeps dumps.
He's gonna kill me.
So uncle Joe got,
I'm a row.
Got Her a revolver.
She'd.
I don't like it.
Just put it under the kind of scared
that I don't like guns.
Never fired it in her life.
No training.
Had no idea,
but she knew which,
which end.
The bullet came out of next time she was
robbed.
She shot the son of a bitch.
She knew what to do.
She knows the trigger and the training.
She one shot the guy that was
threatening her life.
Now they put her in jail initially.
Slake,
you know,
Bernie gets a defendant in his life,
but eventually the charges were dropped
because it was clear and present.
She was defending herself from an
engineered recidivistic write that down,
engineered recidivistic the system in
knowingly and intentionally lets out,
knife and stabbers and rapists and
murderers and child molesters.
They keep letting them out.
Those are the people.
90 six percent of the time that commit
the violent.
When you say engineered,
do you think they do that because of
prison?
Overpopulation,
lack of funds to do it because they want
society to be dangerous.
I can't imagine how the engineered.
I can't imagine that anything is just in
competence and incompetence and the
fusion of responsibility for the
individuals.
Bureaucratic.
Institutionalized irresponsibility.
Yeah,
and corruption and abusive party.
They don't want to deal with it.
Well,
lack of resource.
Cut them a deal.
They only shot three people.
Let's I get them on jaywalking.
Okay.
We'll cut them a deal.
He only serve six years of his life
sentence for killing those people.
I mean it happens all the time and that
guys on the street and he kills
somebody.
Go,
I can't believe it.
He had an arrest record,
goes back to his youth and it was 100
pages lie.
I can't believe you.
Let him out.
Well,
we let them out.
We knew we killed people.
In fact,
he stabbed two people,
but he missed the artery.
So we're going to let them out and see
if he can study anatomy enough and get a
good stab next time that our court
systems are a joke.
Our prison system is a joke.
I mean,
if somebody stabbed somebody,
do you want him?
You want him on the street with you?
If he stabbed somebody,
you are killing that person.
You're just shitty at it.
If you shoot at somebody in your miss
that's murder,
you just,
you're just bad at it.
If you're willing to just throw a bullet
at a human being,
I want him in a cage forever or better
yet,
dead right there.
And then if he's capable of taking an
innocent life,
I want him out of the gene pool.
I don't believe in,
uh,
um,
how did I put it in that one interview?
I don't.
I don't believe in repeat crime.
Repeat criminals.
I believe in dead criminals.
If someone threatens innocent life,
get him Outta here.
I really believe that.
And you know who the best person to make
that decision is?
The person that bought to get stamped,
the lady bought to get raped.
The gigabyte to get shot at this all
makes sense.
I mean,
I,
I feel what you're saying.
I think the real problem is why does it
happen in the first place?
Because we're a society that doesn't
respond to alarming signals in the hope
of not hurting feelings instead of
saving lives.
It's a liberal mantra of a feel good
inaction versus tough choices and harsh
choices that will actually save lives.
Don't you think it's also a lack of
resources to.
And a lack of these people that are
interviewing these psychos before they
snap based on that.
Really,
psychology based on my tax bill.
Um,
I think they have the resources is just
mismanaged and wasted.
By the way,
while we're doing this,
can I hit the bathroom real quick before
I squirmed out of here?
Can I never.
This will be right back
and I came in here.
Will stay here.
Yeah.
Amazing.
You're walking fantastic on those robot
knees,
man.
It's crazy.
It's amazing how few people can hold
their pis.
Sometimes it comes.
Yeah.
He's got to waterstone.
He,
he slammed to waters this.
A shooting happening while he's on is so
appropriate.
I mean,
it's so,
uh,
crazy that this,
this is the time.
So this is a newsroom wide.
They got,
do they have a motivation for this guy?
No motivation is being interrogated
right now is what I just read.
And uh,
it's amazing that these guys want,
they get captured but they don't get
killed like the Parkland kid and the,
a lot of these people like how are they
not killing these people when they're,
when it's happening.
Supposedly a white guy in his twenties.
Is it some fake news thing?
I mean,
he,
he shot reporters,
you know,
until the interrogation comes out.
I feel like it's not fair to say,
but there are people pointing at things
that have been in the news recently.
Oh fuck.
It's just so much.
I mean,
I hear what Ted's saying,
that you should be able to defend
yourself.
And I agree.
Like if you were in a grocery store
somewhere and some guy came in shooting
and you had a gun,
I would want you to be able to defend
yourself.
You know,
I want you to be alive.
I agree with you.
I get that.
But that's the only way.
I mean.
Or is it just what we have to do right
now.
I mean,
I don't know what anybody on the other
side wants other than taking away
everyone's guns.
But if you take away everyone's guns,
how are we possibly going to do an audit
of 300 million guns in this country?
How are you going to find all the
illegal ones?
Are you going to find all the stored
ones?
And then there's that old cliche.
If you outlaw guns,
only outlaws will have guns.
I mean it's almost like the same thing
we're talking about when it,
in terms of legalizing illegal,
illegal drugs and when drugs are legal,
they can be taxed and you can make sense
of the situation.
You can have treatment centers.
The stigma of,
you know,
the,
the appeal of them of doing something
you're not supposed to do is no longer
there and then you're not funding these
illegal organizations.
Organizations like the cartels in Mexico
or back when it was organized crime in
America for alcohol when the prohibition
was going on.
It's,
I don't think that you're going to be
able to take away all these guns,
but I don't know what the argument I
would like to talk to somebody who has
an argument that you could do it because
I know they did it in Australia,
but Australia so small and by the way
you can get guns in Australia.
People use guns for hunting all the
time.
So guns are available and occasionally
they do have gun violence but they had
like one mass shooting in the 19
nineties in Australia and they just
banned all the guns.
But Australians,
are there a different culture too?
Like this fucking culture is gun happy
from all of our movies and television
shows and the solution is like bang,
Bang,
Bang.
Like shooting people as a part of the
solution.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't know,
man,
I just.
No one has an answer.
There's no one on that side.
No one on this side.
Every answer has holes in it.
You're laughing.
What happened?
Our Pis,
I always say,
God,
I love that.
I always say to this conversation about
guns,
you know,
and,
and I don't see an answer.
I do.
I really don't.
I don't see an answer.
The ultimately will be like,
I'm all for responsible gun ownership.
I have guns,
I've hunted with guns,
I believe in gun ownership,
but how do you stop gun violence?
And I don't know.
I don't know what the answer is and I
think this is ultimately what everybody
is trying to find.
We were talking about when you were
gone,
the Australians were,
they banned guns because of one mass
shooting and they've never had a mass
shooting sense,
but doesn't.
Crime continues to go up and down based
on other social factors and there's not
many of them.
There's only 20 million people in the
entire country
to address.
Probably the glaring beast in the room
of America.
You're 50 something,
50,
51 in August,
I'll be 70 and I've had a pretty good
writer.
I got a pretty good absorption factor of
information,
evidence,
experiences,
ideas,
opinions,
activities,
what the hell happened
that would allow Americans so many of us
to become so evil that we want to hurt
each other and kill each other and
it killed children,
rob in and molests so want to make the
biggest impact that hurt the most people
because they're hurt.
Doing what w,
W,
w,
w where did that delineation from a post
World War,
two celebration of the freedoms that
motivated our armed forces to defeat the
worst evil on the planet,
the Japanese Slaughters and the Nazi
devils that it was our constitution and
our individual rights that motivated
these guys to fight harder and you know,
it was a martial artist.
You have to see beyond the contest and
it's almost like you don't,
you don't make your hit where you want
to hit.
You want your hit to go past where you
want to hit.
We were a united nation in 1946,
19,
47 and certainly right,
48 when I was born in Detroit was the
work ethic,
productivity epicenter of planet Earth,
universally known.
We were the war machine that built the
tanks and the bombers and the planes
and,
and pride ownership and,
and you got up early and you busted your
ass to be the best that you can be and
you kept your yard good and you kept
your house clean and you earn your own
way.
And it was an embarrassment not to earn
your own way and you save for a rainy
day and you live within your means and
you discipline yourself.
My,
my upbringing was,
and wasn't poverty.
I was never in need,
but you couldn't drink a whole coke.
You couldn't buy something because you
wanted it.
You needed some socks.
She probably got them for Christmas.
Um,
and if I wanted an Arrow,
I had a,
you know,
go to the pickup garbage and try to sell
golf balls back and,
and,
and bought,
get deposits on bottles and cans.
And yeah,
there was a,
I was the rugged individualism,
the self sufficiency,
the neighborliness,
the giving and caring and you know,
it did take a village.
It started with family,
but you cared about your neighbors and
you watched over each other.
And then I saw and with all due respect,
when the beatniks and the dope and then
the hippies and the disconnect and a
carelessness erupted and and a meanness,
I started seeing more meanness and anger
and and disconnect.
And then after whether it was the new
deal or the great society,
which kind of incentivized not being the
best that you can be and you can
actually stay home and get a check.
And I'm the unions would negotiate not
unquality automobiles but money that may
or may not be there,
but we'll get you some more money and
you can make Chrysler's that won't even
start.
It can't even drive them.
They're such a pile of shit.
And I saw this Detroit go from this
glowing
epicenter of goodwill and decency and
work ethic to Liberal Democrats,
scamming people and bribing people for
votes by getting you something you
didn't know.
And then all of a sudden the city burned
down and no age couches in the street
and refrigerators on the lawns and it
just turned into a lump I shit and it
breaks my heart.
I go downtown Detroit now and building
the beautiful architecture still boarded
up from the 67 riots.
I took my kids down for the 42nd
anniversary of the Amboy Dukes and I
wanted to show him this beautiful city I
was raised in and what happened to it?
And almost for dramatic effect,
almost like Cecil B de Mille was,
you know,
directing a scene for me to emphasize
how deteriorated Detroit got,
here's this guy in a sidewalk with his
pants down,
taking a dump in the middle of the after
known.
And I go,
wow,
I didn't actually hire that guy.
That's really what's happened.
So if you allow your society to crumble
before your eyes without intervening and
go,
hey,
you can't do that.
You go,
hey,
you can't do that.
I've done it with my musicians all my
life.
You Go,
God demo.
We were really rocking last week and now
you're all stoned and can't even wake
you up,
but don't you think that when you're
talking about 1946,
the United States,
we were.
We were all against the Nazis and the
Japanese.
We were united certainly that are our
lives were threatened.
The world's future was threatened and
people felt like they had a purpose.
Purpose.
Do you remember?
I was in.
I was in New York right after September
11 and one of the credit and something
happened.
A friend of mine fainted and we had to
call the fire department.
EMT showed up and the respect and the
happiness that people had when they saw
the first responders,
and I was like,
this is.
This is fascinating because I lived in
New York.
It was,
it was a high point because people had
felt what it was like to be attacked to
be at war.
I mean that was what the attack and the
Trade Center,
the Twin Towers was.
We were at war.
They felt this and they felt united
because of it,
and when these people showed up to help,
they were excited to see them.
They were like heroes.
They treated them like real heroes and I
was like,
this is a different feeling than
anything I've had before and I had.
I had to imagine that this was probably
what it was like in the United States in
the forties fixture in the middle of the
war when people were united working
together to make sure there was enough
scrap metal and enough rubber and there
were car pooling so that they have
enough raw materials to create twine and
rubber bands for the workout.
People felt sacrificing for the benefit
of their society.
Yeah,
and they felt like there was something
real going on.
Whereas when there's no threat and no
worries,
I think people get lost.
I think especially people with no
discipline.
Not Everybody of course,
but some it's.
There's a tendency to get lost.
Then there's a tendency for people to
take advantage of those people that are
lost and say,
it's not your fault.
It's the government's fault and the
government needs to pay you and the
government needs to help out so wrong,
but there's this very strange tendency
that people have and also if I may
exalt,
here I am with Joe Rogan.
We'd never met.
I didn't know much about.
Yes,
everybody was bombarding me.
So you got to go on Joe Rogan's guys.
Reasonable,
sensible,
smart and funny and he's promoting
hunting now and I got motherfuckers.
Sounds like my boy.
Let's go do this.
You have to admit with intelligent,
conscientious,
well-formulated prioritization.
Twenty 18.
We can go on and on about the problems
in the world.
Do you know that I'm the happiest
motherfucker with the greatest band,
the greatest crew,
the greatest family.
Love my TV show and New York Times best
sellers and successful to some degree
and the things that I pursue my passions
and I'm doing your show.
We're talking about important issues and
I have dangerous zone people that come
backstage and we raise money for
charities every night.
Do you know Joe that I can't find a dirt
bag as well,
but a pretty big circle,
but you're a pretty big circle and I
walked down the streets here.
I go to starbucks and get a coffee.
I'll go up there and they pay.
They pay for it for me and I love spirit
of the wild.
Thanks for standing up for our freedoms.
God bless you.
I can't find a dirt bag.
I'm sure I could,
but here's the solute on a Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan podcast to all those people out
there that do intelligently and
responsibly prioritize and they bust
their ass because they're out there.
There's no monster armies of working
hard,
playing hard shit.
Kickers who sacrifice and take risks and
try to start a new business and fall
down in the arena and stand up and brush
themselves off and get back at it.
Those are the people that I want to talk
to right now because they're the best of
the best.
Don't back off
friction.
Don't back off discomforting encounters
whether it's your kid,
because I've got buddies.
Kids died of fentanyl.
Great families
that Fentanyl Shit.
God,
I'll cry for Ya,
and you take them in your arms and they
didn't do anything wrong and they're
burying the fucking kid.
Did you confront him?
Why are you telling me you didn't see
this man?
Here's my alert to people listening to
the upward Ted and Uncle Joe.
Bookie,
look harder,
be more assertive is something doesn't
look perfect.
Look into it,
and if,
if there's needy people instead of
giving them money because they get
probably buy drugs or alcohol and you're
probably going to die if you make a
donation to most homeless people are
going to.
You're helping to kill him.
Brighton there ain't going to buy good
shit with it and Badger.
You're elected employees.
We need to have mental health
facilities.
What?
What are you wasting money on?
You don't need to find out the sex life
of a turtle.
You need to take those billions of grant
money that you're blown right now for
some jack off and you need.
We need to address the mental health,
homeless,
truly needy,
not the greedy,
not the scammers where abled bodied,
they just like to stay home.
The people who have mental issues and
physical issues and that Donald trump
has finally got to a point in time where
you can fire a veteran administration
scam artists.
Punk who doesn't care about the vets,
doesn't show up for work in absconds on
revenues that could have got a couple of
wheelchairs for a legless marine.
Now we can fire the bastards.
So there is upgrade happening.
But those that do know and do care no
more care.
More and,
and,
and demand answers.
Whether it's your family member.
How come,
how come you didn't show up at the
family event?
What are you doing?
Are you high?
Are you using?
What are you doing?
I think if we start family neighbors,
and don't be afraid to tell your
neighbor,
you know,
I saw your son the other day was passed
out at the curb.
I don't think we intervene like we did
back when I was growing up.
Nobody would have tolerated that shit
when I was growing up.
They would have sounded the alarm.
And I don't think there's enough of
that.
Neighborliness,
um,
uh,
not being afraid to hurt feelings.
Well,
it's none of your business.
Well you wrote is my business because
you're,
you're my neighbor and the guy you're
shitting on my lawn.
I mean,
I don't think we're aggressive enough.
I come from a world of aggression,
not,
not being a prick about it,
but asking questions.
At some point you might have to shrug
your shoulders and go away.
He doesn't want any help.
There's nothing I can do,
but I tried.
Well,
you'd like conflict.
You Do,
you do.
I like to eradicate it.
I like to intervene to reduce.
Clearly,
you know that the way you express
yourself is entertaining,
but it's also polarizing like a lot of
things to say,
you know?
Sure.
You invite this sort of.
Not intentionally.
I think by being a pragmatist you're
going to invite conflict because some
people don't like to hear this shit.
Yeah.
Some people don't like to hear this
shit,
but the style in which you talk like
even when you're debating Pierce Morgan,
you're very,
very powerful with the way you describe
things and you,
you,
you get people that want to argue back
with you.
It's time for that because I think the
gentleman's approach,
Mitt Romney and John Mccain,
you didn't represent nothing.
The reason Donald Trump won is because
finally the shit kickers who worked
rough and tumble those construction guys
outside the four seasons.
I stayed at the four seasons.
How cool does that.
They're busting their ass to getting
approved and they're working hard and to
go throw back a few beers and have a
little barbecue at night.
These are the guys I'm talking about and
talking to and they're the ones who
voted for Donald trump.
Finally because he came out,
he wasn't afraid.
He sounded like a shit kicker.
Really sounded like them.
Sound like us.
Yeah.
There's a.
There was a real problem that we have in
this country with people that are career
politicians and he was really the first
problem.
Career politicians is the problem.
The status quo.
That's,
you know,
Donald Trump isn't perfect.
I liked imperfect,
imperfect,
just cool you and me.
Good examples,
but he came in swinging a crow bar to
this horrible status quo that can best
be described as one of.
He's not presidential.
You're goddamn right is not presidential
because all these presents presidential
guys got us into this mess because there
were so cautious and they didn't want to
ruffle any feathers.
We want have a big tent,
including all the bad guys and people
that don't believe in secure borders.
What is that?
And people that don't believe in earning
your own way.
What's that?
People that don't know the difference
between legal immigration and illegal
immigration.
What's that?
So the shit kickers.
Finally her saw somebody busted the
status quo.
You're damn right,
he's not presidential.
Presidential got us into this train
wreck and we're done with it.
So the Republicans better be paying
attention because if you're status quo,
we were not voting for you.
If you come in swing,
you don't have to be rude enough to be
screaming,
don't have to be condemning,
but you have to be honest and forthright
and sound like somebody.
You'd have a beer with it,
a barbecue,
and if you sound like a shit kicker and
one of us working our plane out
Americans and you address our concerns
will vote for you.
If you don't,
we're going to stay in our tree stand in
November,
which is what happened traditionally.
That's why Michigan,
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania with 800,000,
100,
one it for trump because we are a
hunter's nation and those families were
a huge voting block.
They'd never felt like they had skin in
the game.
Finally,
somebody had skin in the game,
including my teamster buddies,
my union buddies,
instead of just like puppets pulling
that deliberately went,
the Democrats had been lying to me.
The Democrats have been scamming me.
I'm voting for trump.
He's a status quo wrecker.
Yeah.
Was uh,
when you say look,
lying and scamming,
what,
what are you,
what are you examples?
Like what do you mean?
Good grief.
But like what?
What gets to you?
Like what is the thing that you,
when you think of Democrats and you
think of lying and how about,
what do you think you need to read this?
You need to cite it to find out what's
in it.
Nancy Pelosi on the House floor with
this huge voluminous healthcare bill
actually said,
you don't need to read it.
You need to cite it to find out what's
in it.
Wow.
You don't remember that?
No.
Holy Shit.
That sounds pretty ridiculous.
She said it and then watch her try to
form a sentence.
Watch maxine water desperately searched
for a syllable.
Listen to the words out of their mouths.
Well,
the Greeks.
Did you see this thing that she was
calling out for people to see anyone in
the administration having dinner?
Including Ted nugent?
Yeah.
Bring it on,
asshole.
Disrupt and cause a crowd.
And tell them what you're not welcomed
every.
That's an insanely irresponsible thing
to say.
That's treacherous.
Every one of my promoters have death
threats because they dare to hire me.
Every one of my band mates and my crew
mates,
some guys that are building this
wonderful,
uh,
a bell amplifier,
the,
they just showed a picture on their
website with me testing the new
amplifier and people attacked him and
threatened to kill them because they're
working with the coward animal murderer
or the the gun nut.
I'm a gun nut.
I'm also,
I'm a screwdriver not to,
but that's what I'm saying about you
being this polarizing figure that people
that aren't looking too deeply into it
or listening to everything you say,
but you can was thing how.
How else can you address it?
Because that's why I'm asking.
Well,
I'm telling you,
you know Joe,
the guys who have tried own very polite
and a very nonconfrontational got us
into this mess.
If you don't believe America needs
secure borders,
you're the enemy of America.
You need secure.
Who doesn't know you need secure
borders?
Nancy Pelosi doesn't.
Hillary Clinton didn't have Loretta
Lynch didn't.
I mean,
come on.
These people are freaks.
America first pisses off Democrats.
How can that be if it's not America
thinkers,
think of it as you're denying
opportunity to people that live in an
impoverished third world country that's
connected to us.
Think of it as racism.
All my ancestors came through Ellis
Island and did mine and denounce their
allegiance to where they came from.
You can still cook Swedish and still
cook German,
but you got an announce allegiance to
where you come from because you're
coming here.
Of the habits pages per night,
fucking hard for someone to come over
from Mexico and don't you think that the
real problem is that Mexico sucks or
they parts of Mexico sock overall.
You figure out a way to help those
people.
Really the only way would be to make
Mexico so healthy and and and a great
place to live.
That it's just like the United States.
There's no reason to come over here and
certainly we have tried.
Our policies have been very generous to
those countries were in fact we're the
only country that has been generous to
them,
but the massive.
Yeah,
massive corruption.
Hire Mexican,
Guatemalan.
All those governments are as criminals.
Al Capone in Chicago and 32.
I mean,
so infested by the law enforcement is
the cartel.
The military is the cocktail,
so where do you next?
We have the right to secure,
but this is not my opinion.
We in America have the right and the
responsibility to secure our borders.
If you think otherwise,
your dangerous.
We need to break.
I want people who need a better quality
of life.
I welcome them.
I got buddies that came like that,
my,
my sound man,
frank went through the seven year
process from Germany and now he's
illegal citizen in America.
Why should someone be able to swim
across the Rio Grande and circumvent all
that process so we know whether you're
going to be an asset or a liability.
It's not rocket science.
It's liability or asset.
We want assets and that's why our
immigration system is horrific.
Even the legal one,
so I know it's a problem,
but we're putting all these resources
and man hours into securing the poorest
border instead of processing those who
legitimately would like a better quality
of life in America,
but first they have to.
We have to differentiate between the
protesters who think that we need to
turn over California and Arizona and
Texas back to Mexico so it can turn into
a shit hole.
Of course,
left Mexico.
They know it's horrible.
That's why they're here.
Why would you come here to get away from
a Shithole and then turn the place you
came to into the shit hole.
We have a constitution.
We have a bill of rights.
You need to earn your own way.
You need to work very hard if you're in
the asset column,
I love you.
If you're in the liability column,
I love you if you're having hard times,
but if you have squatted intentionally
as an able bodied individual in that
liability column,
you are a detriment to America and you
should get the fuck outta here.
That's when you look at it in
perspective.
The people that are able bodied
Americans that don't do Jack Shit and
some poor bastard is trying to do
anything they can to get here from
Mexico to the point where they're
literally dying and hydration in the
desert.
Yeah,
and they would bust their ass if given
that opportunity.
So it's not fair.
It's not easy and it's never going to be
easy advocated,
but.
But it is doable.
But our priorities as a government are
so clustered.
There's so just prioritized that all
this efforts going towards securing the
Rio Grande when people are illegally
swimming across and jeopardizing their
very life and limb when just down a
couple of miles.
There's a legal entrance and it might be
a pain in the ass,
but you're here with me today,
June 28th,
20,
2018.
Have you not put up with major pains in
the ass as a martial artist,
as a comedian,
that's a tough life.
You got your world carved out because
you put up with a pain in the ass and
you.
Oh,
you improvise,
adapt and overcome.
It makes you happier at night.
It was very fortunate.
I was born in America.
I,
you know,
I didn't grow up in an impoverished
crime ridden community.
Understood to deal with gang violence,
but you're certainly not advocating them
coming in illegally.
No,
I just think there's gotta be.
There's gotta be a better conversation
about this and I think that the
conversation is that if you oppose these
people that are illegal,
immigrating illegally,
immigrated into this country,
that you're a racist.
So is what's going on right now.
My Bass player,
Mark Mendoza's,
I'm Mexican and my bass player,
Johnny gunnels,
a black guy,
but it's simple to call people racist.
Like people love to do that.
They love to reduce you down that,
but it's cruel.
It's,
it's ignorance.
It's a denial of nuance.
So that's a,
that's a tsunami of accusations against
me.
And I've always made it perfectly clear
throughout my 70 year life,
I have always judged by content of
character,
never by color of skin.
I have to admit there is a racist
element in me because I'm going to
expect a black guy to be able to play
better groove than a white guy that has
been,
uh,
had been overruled over the years
because there's so many white guys that
learned from the black masters that now
it is raceless.
But in growing up,
I always figured the black guy would be
a better musician.
I'm in a racist against white people in
the early days it was that way.
Um,
but nowadays we learn from those black
soul artists that were the consummate
definitive authority of emotional music
from the James Brown,
the funk brothers and chuck and Bo and
little Richard and bb and Freddy and
Albert and Ali's monster black heroes of
everybody's.
And there's not a musician in the world
that won't admit that.
But now,
because of that influence all these
years,
uh,
the white boys,
um,
can keep right up there with them.
In fact,
in many instances,
a compared to a lot of the rap and the
hip hop,
um,
there's a whole lot of white guys out
there.
I think a job on a Masa and Anton Fagan,
certainly Jason Heartless and Greg Smith
and all the guys narrows Smith and Zz
top.
I mean,
you close your eyes and there's not a
Caucasian to be found in these bands
nowadays soul wise.
So yeah,
it raised the,
the,
the repugnant.
I'm dishonest.
Charge of racism is completely.
It's one that you can't shake.
Just somebody calls you a racist and
heat it,
but people have called you a racist.
Everybody,
everybody with a heart and a soul knows
I'm not in a,
you have,
you know,
you know who the racists are.
People that call me a racist.
Those are the racists while and dirt
bags to be.
It's just,
it's an unfair thing to do that people
like to do because it automatically puts
you on the defensive.
You're automatically on your heels and
you have to defend this charge against
raising by proving you're not a racist,
which makes people suspicious that you
might be raised and Speidel.
Yeah.
I'm just,
I just live a great life with great
people and race,
creed,
ethnicity,
religion,
gender,
confusion matters.
What do you think about that?
I think,
I think Caitlin,
because I beat him in all the races we
raced against.
That's what it is.
I pray for Bruce.
Katelyn.
Like,
what a great guy or a girl.
Now I will,
if that's what he said,
if that's what she likes.
It's a weird one,
right?
Yeah.
Where was this when you were a kid?
Yes.
It's,
it's,
it's a different arena of thought.
Um,
and only she can make that choice and
you have to respect that choice.
It,
it's mind twisting,
twisting in.
Anybody says it's not,
it's not being honest,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's very strange.
Diane Sawyer.
God love her,
but she had the opportunity of a
lifetime when she was interviewing bruce
and he was saying,
you know,
for all practical purposes,
um,
I'm a,
I'm a woman.
And she said she should've said,
yeah,
except for the Dick.
But I raced against her if she did say I
wish like that man.
Uh,
but I,
I,
I got to be friends with Bruce.
He was the god of manliness.
Yeah,
the gold medalist on everything.
It was just the,
the baddest motherfucker hurdled the
earth.
And I raced with them in off road races
and stuff and I always beat him,
which was just shit luck because I was
more aggressive.
And uh,
he was a great guy and I spent a
suspect.
He's still,
she's still a great gal.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I respect everyone's choice to do
whatever you want as long as we're
reading people.
And that fills right into that category.
Absolutely.
How many people have come to you that
you run into in,
in all your,
your,
you know,
your circles and musicians and the son
of a bitch,
like,
curious about hunting that didn't know
where to start because that's one of the
things that comes to me a lot.
People like I want to get it.
I have so many comedians is great,
isn't it?
Yeah.
And they don't know how to get started.
And I'm like,
man,
I wish I had the time to take you,
but I don't,
I barely have enough time to go myself.
I've witnessed you articulate it and
you're doing a great job and I thank you
for that and I salute you and you've
made great progress in inroads in that
arena of ignorance and a
presumptuousness.
But I'm very blessed because I'm a loud
mouth and I'm alive.
I mean I'm engaged.
I exercised my duties as we the people
to talk about policies and getting the
face of my elected employees and hold
them to constitutional accountability.
And I'm like,
I missed the concord bridge.
So I'm here doing this now.
And I in my everyday walk at the Sushi
restaurant at the gas station,
at the feed mill,
at the charity event.
People always coming up.
And those that would hesitate,
I guess never showed up because I never
felt any hesitation.
They're always genuinely intrigued.
And they express,
um,
confusion and uncomfortableness,
discomfort with the concept of killing
game.
Uh,
but within minutes when I talk about
sustained yield,
habitat carrying capacity,
just simple,
readily understood earthly logistics,
um,
they go,
I never thought of it like that before
he,
even,
whether they're going to have babies
next year and there's not going to be
any new ground,
we're going to have to grow next year as
wildlife on the existing habitat and in
most cases reduced habitat.
But thank God the cougars can live in
your backyard and the bears can live in
the Culdesac and Pennsylvania and
coyotes that live in your bathroom if
you don't lock the door.
So wildlife has adapted miraculously.
I mean geese and ducks and turkeys and
deer and elk and bear.
They're literally everywhere.
Check out,
uh,
at estes park in Colorado.
I mean their,
their landscaping,
destructo derby.
So we don't need to worry about
encroaching on habitat because they will
adapt and they have wonderful.
And again,
more deer,
more elk,
more cougar,
more bare,
more tricky,
more geese than ever in recorded
history.
And we're slaughtering them by the
gazillions every year because they
growed gazillions every year.
And once I expressed it to people like
that,
and then I inject the,
the inescapable truism you talk organic,
you talk close to the earth quality,
real food.
Is there something better than venison
eye?
Because if there is,
I want some of this conversation is what
I'm talking about.
People don't know how to get started.
They hear about that and there's all
this talk about organic and you know,
close to nature and being connected to
your food,
but they don't know how to.
It's pretty easy to start a garden if
you have a yard,
but to,
to start hunting.
That's a great barrier to entry there
is.
But it's easily overcome.
Um,
and go again,
go to my facebook.
I mean not just to be made my facebook,
but I am the,
the glow worm of the hunting lifestyle.
I mean,
people have always come to me for that
because I've always promoted it and I've
never backed down and almost every
interviewer brings it up since the 19
sixties because it was the tip of the
culture work.
Controversial spear.
It really was hunting and guns.
Those are the tip of the culture war
from the beginning because people were
moving from urban self-sufficient,
hunting,
fishing,
trapping,
earthly lifestyles to the city where
they were catered to and they didn't
hear the chickens squawking,
so they didn't feel responsible for its
death.
Right.
If you haven't caught on blue era
killer,
yeah.
That is the problem.
When I,
when I expressed that,
they go,
hey,
you got a point there and I went,
yeah,
I think so.
I use blunt street term nomenclature and
easily identified colloquialisms of of
modern terminology that is timeless and
it it registers with them quickly now
getting over the hump to have access to
hunting ground.
I also have been effective in educating
people on that because everybody's got
an uncle Joe.
Everybody's got access to some state or
federal open ground and even though the
hunting isn't very quality on those
public areas,
oftentimes if you are willing to pursue
what should have inspired you to ask
about hunting and that means to go
beyond the beaten path,
which is part of the spiritual
experience.
Leaving the modern Kush and getting into
a wild area.
I find that a lot of my new,
uh,
baptized hunting,
young,
old and otherwise,
that they like going deep and they will
find that deer that's not on the fringes
of public ground,
that have already been so pressured that
they moved into the anterior nucleus of
more sanctuary habitat.
And these guys,
it's almost cry.
They're so happy.
Even if they didn't get something
because I got in there and it took me
two hours to get in.
There was still dark and I was concerned
about my safety.
I'd never been that deep in the woods
before the manistee national forest
in Michigan or any wild ground.
Colorado,
Wyoming,
Montana,
California.
And they said,
you're right,
ted.
It's changed my life.
Just watching that deer come down.
I forgot to draw my bow.
So it,
it,
it's an immediate
alive snus that is rarely available in a
modern setting except for great family
times.
Birth,
death,
sex,
laughter around a campfire,
primal moments,
primal,
primal moments.
Yes.
I call it a prayer for the wild things.
I actually wrote this in the New York
Times,
way back in the,
uh,
I guess it was the eighties.
I wrote a New York Times Sunday magazine
feature about my Christmas Buck and I've
written it in all kinds of places and
I'm amazed that people still question
whether I'm serious about hunting or
not.
I bet you kidding me.
I've written New York Times bestsellers
and the number one showing up your
channel for 30 years almost.
Who questions whether or not you're
serious about hunting?
Yeah,
I did.
Someone actually questions?
Yeah,
just did not sure what it's all about.
Um,
well they don't know what it's all
about.
Being receptive to my statements are
just a,
how can you not?
How can you avoid them?
I mean there's many people that would
hear about you and then immediately go,
oh,
fuck that guy.
I heard him talk sit.
He said fuck.
And he called somebody a motherfucker.
Shit.
He did something.
And you've never been on the street.
Really the street.
You've never been on the street.
You've never heard this language before.
You lying sack of shit.
Being this polarizing guy though,
does it get exhausting?
Like so many people hungry in Tom faker
rating.
You don't get tired of constantly doing
well in battle with people,
but I don't,
I don't do battle.
I merely put out the truth,
logic,
common sense,
the science.
It's irrefutable.
It's not my opinion.
I have no opinion on.
And I'm just genuflect at the altar of
truth,
logic,
common sense of science.
And I share it.
And if you can't grasp it,
you work on it.
And I'm here if you need me.
Um,
but you clearly like it.
You liked Pierce Morgan interviews?
Yes.
Because without me,
who's going to do it right there lies
will stand their,
their,
their dishonesty.
And they're mean spirited.
Well,
why do you think they have these low?
Why do you think a good cause?
There's.
Morgan does.
He's been so removed.
They are so satisfied that they say
five.
They think their cord on blue didn't
die.
They think that their pulled pork
sandwich came like that.
And,
and within just minutes,
an honest person will admit that they're
Tofu.
Salad has a whole bunch of dead ground
squirrels and it's vapor trail.
And,
but unless they're,
unless I tell them then what nobody else
can I tell them,
well,
another thing that's a big spot,
if they don't understand where
conservation money comes from,
when you talk to them about the Pickman
Robertson or talk to them about how many
billions of dollars every year and
generated from sales of ammunition,
hunting gear,
bows and arrows and all that stuff.
We selfimposed that the hundreds before
our time.
But yeah,
the hunters.
There wasn't before my time,
but yeah,
it was that.
Well a 30 the dingle Robert Pitchman,
he edited.
It was almost a Teddy Roosevelt thing,
but the real battle cry was in my
lifetime.
We.
There was no anti hunting.
First 10 years of my life.
It was the concrete jungle citification
removal from the system by which we are
sustained.
That was a convenient disconnect and you
could deny it because you didn't hear
the animals die,
didn't see the blood.
It was nice and cleaned up in the little
cellophane package.
And then this is new over the last few
generations and that denial metastasized
into a cult of make believe and fantasy.
But to their credit,
and there is only a lunatic fringe,
I don't believe that the animal rights,
even though they've succeeded,
and in California,
they are run into dead end brick wall
everywhere else.
Even though in Michigan the dirtbags
succeeded in banning the hunting of the
number one game animal on planet earth.
The morning dove where we grow more
doves in Michigan than all the quail
pheasant,
woodcock and grouse combined.
That's a weird one,
right?
Because Doug's been people who've never
eaten,
dove.
They don't know the delicious.
And you hear about a dub,
you go,
wait a minute.
That's piece.
You can't shoot p.
This is.
This isn't an analogy of everything
that's wrong in America,
you're killing piece.
You're killing piece.
But what is a lunatic fringe though?
It really is a lunatic fringe.
It's.
It's a convenient opinion because it
seems like it's sensible.
Yeah.
You're shooting a dove.
Why would you shoot a dove Ted,
and you're like,
listen,
I'm going to cook up some dub for you.
And then you tell me why wouldn't shoot
it up?
Is it okay to shoot a chicken?
It's not okay to shoot a dove.
Why is it okay to shoot a pheasant is
not as you have much to pragmatic joe
and watched the logic.
You might hurt somebody.
Conversations don't take place.
Thank you.
Thank God you've been baptized because
this has a great impact because your
average listener does not come to
hearing haunting truth.
Your average listener comes to hear
smart ass a dialogue in issue review and
intellectual analysis of life's
experiences.
All good,
all perfect,
but that you have inflicted and injected
the truth about conservation wise use
wildlife management is a Hallelujah
moment,
which is why I'm sitting across from you
today because I value that and a lot of
it I got honestly from people like you
that were enthusiastic about it.
That got me curious.
When I saw how enthusiastic you are
about hunting and about the eating of
wild meat and how much energy it gives
you.
I got very curious many years before I
ever started hunting because because I.
I saw a lot of those p to videos.
We see these horrific conditions in
factory farms and I didn't want to be a
part of that was trying to figure out
how to not be a part of that and so when
I first decided to start hunting,
but before that I was making two
decisions,
either I'm going to do this and I'm
going to hate it and I'm never going to
do it again and I'm going to be a
vegetarian or I'm going to become a
hunter,
and the moment I shot that deer and then
we ate it,
I was like,
oh,
I'm doing this forever.
Metrics.
Zuckerberg actually came out and
admitted that if he's going to eat
flesh,
he's going to kill it himself,
but he did it for a whole year and
everything he ate,
he killed.
You know,
and I think that people would have a
better understanding of what their food
is and when you have these conversations
with people,
when it talks,
when it comes to animal rights ideas and
what shouldn't,
shouldn't be legal 90,
what,
five 97 percent of the people eat meat.
I mean,
it's a crazy number.
It's our life support system.
Proteins,
food and people will think you're just
going to stop that.
Listen,
you're going to get a lot of people that
aren't healthy.
This is not the way to go,
and if some people want to go vegan and
they can pull it off with careful
studying of their diet and making sure
they're supplementing with all the right
things,
good luck.
Go.
Go for it.
How we can initiate this conversation.
After my great hero,
Fred Bear,
died in 1987.
It was the next year I started the Ted
nugent camp for kids,
which was a a movement forward of what
he told me to continue promoting
conservation and hunting the way I was,
so I started a charity 500,
one c,
three church did the Ted nugent camp for
kids where we run in Colorado,
South Dakota,
Nebraska,
and Iowa.
Every year we graduated over 16,000 boys
and girls between the ages of seven and
17 from great volunteers,
men and women from every measurable walk
of life that I have to vet because it's
got my name on it,
but a great heroes of law enforcement,
military and just great families and we
teach them the discipline of archery,
the discipline of wildlife management
colluding.
If you don't fish upon the fish will,
if they'll overpopulate and they'll die
off that you have to harvest a surplus
to make room for the next productivity
and trapping the importance of trapping
that that's how you keep disease under
control and that's how you keep value to
fur bearers.
And that's how you make really great,
great warm clothes and at laterals and
fly fishing and the meticulous detail
and discipline of tying flies and being
clean and sober and being the best that
you can be.
And self sufficiency and rugged
individualism.
So this has been going on since 1989.
And,
uh,
still you haven't read a word about it.
New York Times.
You haven't worried about it anywhere
because they're too quick to condemn me
because I'm so good at promoting hunting
gun ownership that they.
They avoid me like the plague,
but the real tragedy is that outdoor
life field and stream sports,
field guns and Ammo,
all of these sporting publications,
not a word,
30 years
of a wonderful charity created by a
household name celebrity about the most
important things in life.
They just don't care.
It's so.
I'm mentioning it here on the Joe Rogan
podcast because my volunteers have been
doing God's work for all these years and
plus people have been very generous to
Shukar Safaris,
donate money every year and people just
dig deep and make donations to keep the
camp alive.
So if people want to find out about
that,
then go to my website,
but it's a charity for children about
being aware of resource stewardship and
hands on boots on the ground.
Environmentalism.
If you're going to cut a tree,
you might want to plant 50 simple.
I know you do a lot of that.
We do a lot of that tree planting and
you've.
You've done every year since [inaudible]
69.
I've got forest in Michigan.
I mean giant towering forest.
It's fun to kill deer on your own grads
fund to kill deer anywhere.
It's exciting and it's challenging.
It's all the good things both to me to
do it on your own ground that you
earned.
It's really special,
but when you do it on the ground that
you earned and you literally built the
forest,
it's,
it's spiritual.
It's almost like.
I love aetate when I'm in my forest.
Well,
I remember you had,
I don't remember who it was.
He had some rock and roll guy on your,
uh,
Sebastian Bach.
I think one time it was one of one of
the guys.
But you were,
you were talking about how someone was
saying,
this is amazing.
I wish I had my own thoughts.
Was Great.
Yeah,
it was that.
That was Steven Tyler and Joe
snored in your own forest.
I said,
you snorted the upper peninsula.
Who are you kidding?
And they did you add a mine here?
He could have bought one hell of a nice
ranch.
He would admit that the life that you
live that life,
uh,
having this,
you essentially live in an area in both
places when Michigan into taxes,
you hunt in your own environment,
you have your own hunting place,
but it's controversial.
And this is what's controversial about
it.
The fence,
well,
the,
the Texas property is fenced because I
have exotic,
so by law in why do I have it fenced
whatsoever exotics,
because if it wasn't fenced with
exotics,
exotics would have probably been extinct
by now,
but land owners in Texas,
we took the lead from South Africa and a
lot of people don't know this Joe.
In fact,
I articulated in an upcoming spirit of
the wild show,
high fence hunting saved wildlife in
Africa because the,
the development of agriculture in Africa
was in total conflict with the migration
of wildlife.
We're talking all those incredible
species from Eland and Kudu and GMS,
Bach in Yallah and willdabeast and,
and,
and the wart hogs.
And in elephants,
they would migrate every year and have
Gulf sudden the migration came to your
citrus grove and destroyed everything.
You had killed all the wildlife.
Because you want to sell your citrus.
Well,
some of the ranchers who value the
wildlife more than citrus and there's
nothing wrong with citrus.
They literally said,
God dammit,
everytime I herds migrate,
only a portion of them come back because
they all these agric concerns are
destroying,
killing the wildlife to protect your
agriculture.
So I'm an offense my 20,000 acres and
I'm going to manage it.
Twenty thousand acres is huge.
Even my spirit world,
ranches,
300 acres,
it's still has a finite productivity.
Every habitat is finite and so they
started selling those hunts for the
surplus every year of these magnificent
wildlife species instead of agriculture.
So those animals are thriving and
absolute natural habitat as is my home,
ground spirit,
wild ranch in Texas,
you must harvest the surplus fence or no
fence and mark my words,
people who condemn and criticize high
fence hunting is not fair.
Chase are speaking out of their ass.
Ted nugent hunts more days in an average
year than most people will in their
lifetime.
I hunt hundreds of days every morning,
every afternoon.
The animals have to die.
I must make room for next year's
productivity.
In your situation,
in all situation,
in your situation in particular because
you're only on 300 acres.
That's right.
I have a certain amount of animals and
habitat.
Everybody even on outside my fence.
You still gotta kill them animals too,
but a lot of like purists would look at
that and go,
man,
is that really hunting?
I mean,
here's my answer.
Read in areas.
You're ready?
Yeah.
Lifetime experience hunting.
You know,
most difficult animals in the world.
The most challenging animals in the
world.
Pressured are my pressured animals and
spirit.
One ranch on my open,
1100 acres,
swamp and Michigan.
If I want to shoot a deer,
I can 90 percent plus tell you with all
my different choices of tree stands and
my strategies of wind and and habitat
and positioning.
Bader,
no bait,
just travel corridors.
I've been living there.
I've owned it since 1978.
In fact,
the one place I've owned since 1970 I.
I have a like a 20 times the shot
opportunity on my open ground than I do
on my fence ground.
My high fenced hunting and all the high
fenced hunting I've ever had is,
is absolutely pure fair chase is any
wilderness I've ever been to from the
Sudan to Alaska,
to Saskatchewan,
to Ontario,
to Montana,
to Wyoming,
to northern California.
It is hunting the role the fence plays
is zero in my killing an animal.
It only plays a role in keeping pressure
outside,
so I don't have to shoot that two or
three or four year old buck.
I can wait till he's five,
but I still have to kill those fidgety
dose and it's absolutely pure hunting.
I understand your
perspective.
The way the way people disagree is that
the idea that these animals can never
leave.
They're stuck.
They're stuck there so you know that
they're going to be there,
which is the difference between that and
like say you go into a back country
hunt,
you know you park your truck and the
trailhead and hike in twitch and tried
to do.
I'm sure you do these animals,
you have no idea if they're.
They are not white ranch.
You have no idea whether they're right,
but you know,
you don't have to have,
I'm sure you know,
you have a lot of them,
right.
It's just,
it's a different thing to be both,
but then again,
it's like do people have a problem
fishing in a stock pond or in a pond?
It's not stocked but managed on my
property so that I fish it adequately
enough so that the basket to be six,
seven and eight pounds,
but I don't let them get stunted.
Same thing.
Those fishing going anywhere and quite
honestly in those suburban areas and
urban areas and even farming across
America.
Those deer are there.
Yeah,
they are there and I have no better
chance of shooting deer and spirit wild
ranch and the high fence than I do
hunting the suburbs of Columbus,
Ohio where those deer can go everywhere
except that there is a highway right
there and there's a hospital over there
and there's a school over there and
there's a neighborhood over there and
there was a factory over here.
So every habitat has its limitations.
Yeah.
I had a conversation with someone about,
um,
access deer and Lanai.
We just got back from Lanai.
Awesome.
Populated there.
It's crazy overpopulated.
So I said there's two irresponsible,
20,000 axis deer and 3000 people on this
island.
And so someone says to me,
what's the challenge in that?
I'm like,
Oh,
Christ,
you never seen an axis so uppity.
They are white,
are the most weird species this side of
bungle and uh,
I'm going to say mature,
Kudu,
these guys,
Tango Bango is a huge antelope.
It's actually orange with black and
white stripes from the Central African
Republic and Cameroon.
And so they evolved to get away from
lions,
whereas the axis deer evolved to get
away from tigers.
Yup.
Yeah.
Just anything that lives around cats
like mule deer,
high country,
we're just switched on or looking for
Michigan deer because there's so many
hundreds of either pressure from the
time they're with.
That's the thing about your place in
Michigan.
In Michigan,
it's very hard to find a large,
mature deer,
not on our property because what I'm
saying,
we stopped shooting young ones and all
the neighbors agree just like they did
in Buffalo County,
Wisconsin,
which is all just decisions by
contiguous land owners to not shoot
young bucks because somebody shot a $200
and then when we get that,
I went on my farm so they knew they were
there.
That's why I was so popular because deer
hunting was not popular in guys were
shooting six and seven year old mammoths
and so the hundreds that started deer
hunting went well.
I'm not shooting at two year old,
you know,
bulger buck because joe down the road
got a,
got a massive stag.
I'm going to wait for one of them and by
waiting them they do
get older and they do have that
mysticism of stagnant,
which is better for the population
because of the bad guy gets to breed
geared and spread those good genetics.
Talk about that to let people go.
Trophy hunting takes out the best jeans.
Yeah,
no,
it does not understand.
We keep.
We keep setting records for deer and
Moose and elk and Caribou and bear and
mountain lion and antelope every year.
We set world records constantly because
our hunting system of being disciplined
and waiting for that mature animal are
hunting system,
has produced the healthiest most
monstrosity specimens in the history of
record keeping every year,
so we're not hurting anything by being
disciplined and patient,
which I've learned over the years and my
son is very adamant about in so many
hunters are.
There's A.
There's a mysticism to that mature stag.
The breeders of our ancestors were the
best hunters and they did the breeding
because they were more resourceful and
more intelligently connected to the
system by which we fed the tribe.
So those,
those killer stag hunters were always
the leader of,
of uh,
of tribes.
And in it's still that way today I'd
like to think and also this pursuit of
bowhunting,
which is more difficult and more
rewarding because it's more difficult,
is many levels more difficult when
you're chasing after a 200 inch box.
Because this is a six,
seven year old animal that's been
avoiding mountain lions and bears and
whatever else is trying to eat it for
years and years,
this thing is switched on.
They take very clever paths.
They let the dose and the Fonz Wander on
first and they laid back and typically
come out around,
turn to come out about midnight and go
back to bed around one.
Now there is a variance there in south
Texas where a age management was created
because they they supplement and they
got a center pivot agriculture down in
the deserts of south Texas and that
genetic is a very fortified genetic.
Anyhow,
200 pound deer are not that rare.
A lot of people think all deer in Texas
are little,
but they're not,
and if you let them grow,
which texts is pretty much pioneered.
Those bucks in south Texas are the
easiest deer on the planet to kill and
there's a couple of dynamics.
There's just some strange genetic
lineage there that they're a calmer
animal.
Plus they're on wide open,
vast private ground,
which means they don't get the public
hordes of pressure and once that book is
a button buck the first year,
nobody shoots at him,
so he encounters.
He smells that person,
he sees that person,
he hears that person.
No problem.
Second year,
a little booger.
Buck,
you ran into people.
Nobody.
Nobody messed with him.
Third Year she's got a nice little rack.
You still run into people.
No problem.
There's some corn is where the
wheat field is the.
I smelled that guy,
but male,
three years,
he's never bothered me.
I'll just keep you in fourth year,
same thing.
So they reduce their fear factor of the
encounter with humans because nobody
shot at them because they're not going
to shoot him.
There is that natural,
but probably isn't with nappy
considered.
Like that's weird.
It's almost like this is a pet or a
farmer about that.
I mean,
I'm just a relaxed animal that he's not
pressured,
which not just relaxed but accustomed to
humans.
Yes.
But they're still elusive.
You're not going to walk up to them and
club.
Um,
though,
there are some places down there where
they get so relaxed that they do hand
feed some of the dose.
They get so relaxed.
That seems so strange to me.
Well,
but everybody's got their own little
preference and I,
I've never thought of wildlife as pets.
I just wouldn't own a deer as a pet.
I would.
You're asking for trouble and it's not
natural,
but if that's what you like,
um,
have a nice day.
Well,
you know,
those farms,
uh,
the deer farms,
that's one of the primary ideas of the
source of CBC Cwd,
right?
No,
they think that a lot of it comes from
deere phones came from Colorado
Department of Wildlife.
What do you mean?
Nineteen,
67.
They injected scrapers,
which is the sheep version of the
sponge.
A forum and stuff elect me into the mule
deer in 1967 and they got out.
That's where it started.
Why did they inject?
I can not imagine bureaucrats be an
Asshole,
I suspect.
And so that is some sort of experiment.
I don't know the,
you know,
the sheep were more popular in America
than cattle.
There were way more sheep and cattle
until scrape.
These came in,
which is that that cwd version for
sheep,
mad cow and bovines and Crutchfield,
Jacob and humans,
and of course,
crutchfield.
Jacob was a result to scientists
determined by the scientists,
crutchfield end Jacob,
that the Indonesians,
people that got this,
the sponge of forum,
a condition from a prion because they
ate the brains of their conquered
enemies.
Never a good idea.
So,
so I'm aware of all this stuff,
but believe me when I tell you live on
the Joe Rogan podcast,
the cwd hysteria is a scam.
More deer are killed in Michigan every
year by feral dogs.
Then all the deer ever worldwide by cwd.
I think the concern though with cwd is
that it's spreading.
It's not my friend Doug,
his farm in Wisconsin,
they're just starting to test positive
for cwd know why?
Because they're looking for it.
Well,
it's not just that they were looking for
it before,
but they think that it's come from
animals that get out of these high fence
farm operations where they all feed from
the same trough and they they,
they spread this from there.
I think there's no evidence to support
that.
Dr James Crow just testified with me in
front of the Michigan Natural Resource
Commission
and Department of Natural Resources and
all the exhaustive studies have
concluded that cwd cannot be cross
species.
You can't get by eating.
Person.
Person can't get it.
They they had on macaque monkeys get up,
but that's because the injected massive
quantities into the brain of a cop
monkey.
Otherwise they couldn't get in.
But cwd Wisconsin spent $70,000,000.
I'm not making that number up.
Wisconsin spent $70,
million dollars,
tried to eradicate certain hers,
which is a virtual impossibility by the
way,
and even if you were successful,
the the mutated prion,
they,
they stay in the ground typically
through urine and there isn't a part of
plants as well.
There was no evidence whatsoever that
cwd is ever compromised.
A servant heard it.
There's been no reduce seasons even in
the epicenter,
the endemic areas of Colorado,
Wyoming where it started,
where it's the most prevalent.
No seasons have been reduced,
no reduced tags,
no reduced in harvest.
It's in consequential.
It occurs so rarely.
They've studied the deer for 18 years in
Wisconsin and deer that had cwd 18 years
collared and monitored.
Still having funds,
they say it's always fatal.
It is not always fatal.
Go to the doctor,
dear a slash facebook.
Either Dr Dr. Com slash facebook or
failure.
You're not worried about it at all.
Not worried about bureaucrats that have
scared away hunters in Wisconsin and
caused butchers to quit processing deer
because of the manufactured hysteria.
CWD is not a concern.
Buicks kill more deer than cwd it,
it,
it.
The bureaucrats go in and slaughtered
dear by the thousands.
So if cwd is killed,
58 deer in Michigan,
which has,
they found,
um,
I don't think any of them were fatal.
I think they had to kill him though they
did find one in Jackson County.
They claim,
I don't believe,
I just don't believe bureaucrats.
Remember,
these are the bureaucrats.
Joel in Michigan that claimed that there
were quote 5,000 to 7,000 Russian boar
running wild and Michigan.
Can we analyze that,
analyze that claim for a moment?
Maybe you can tell me Joe,
what the fuck is a Russian boy?
I'll tell you what a Russian boar is.
It's a male pig in Russia.
There is no such genius as a Russian
boar.
It's all wives tale bullshit.
That was the official statement by a
game agency in Michigan.
Lions,
sons of bitches and then they claim,
and here's another one.
So isn't it our moral and spiritual
obligation to wisely use the animals we
harvest,
isn't it?
Yes.
In Michigan,
the farmers can slaughter sandhill
cranes,
which are known as rib eye in the sky,
right?
It's supposed to be delicious.
It is farmers and Michigan's can can
shoot sandhill cranes,
but by law are not allowed to eat them.
What is this a game department you can
trust?
Wait a minute,
don't.
I will not.
Wait a minute.
You heard me right?
You're not allowed to eat sand.
This game department is going to try to
tell me about wildlife management when
they claimed there were 6,000 or 70,000
Russian born.
By the way,
let's say there were 6,000,
5,000 to 7,000 wild pigs and Michigan
back when they claimed it in the
nineties.
You know how many that would be today?
Show me some game cameras.
800,000 deer hunters in Michigan.
What are there?
10,
20,000 game cameras.
It's a lie.
Cwd is ally cwd as killed 58 deer in
Michigan,
so they claim the dnr has authorized the
slaughter of tens of thousands.
Who's the enemy of the deer hunter?
The bureaucrats are.
I'm telling you in Michigan they have
lost their souls.
It's a heartbreaker.
I can't understand the rationale for not
eating sandhill cranes.
There is none.
What w?
What are they saying?
When you shoot them,
you have to just let them rot bay.
You have to bury.
So we're shooting them as a nuisance
animals that the idea,
even if even if that's.
That's the idea,
but here's the.
Here's the truth,
here's the guitar tags.
The guitar player will help.
Okay.
If there's enough sand,
no cranes for farmers to shoot open the
season,
sell licenses,
create a management plan and show some
decency and respect and let us eat the
rib eye in the sky.
You stupid bastards.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Now,
see,
I'm confrontational now,
but because I've been confronted with an
offensive,
a criminal law that forbids us to
utilize God's precious protein.
This is bizarre world that doesn't make
any sense.
It doesn't make any sense that the
morning who the picture of the dove on
millions of boxes of Ammo in Michigan,
there's a picture of a dove and it says
game load,
but the Michigan Dnr will say,
oh no,
no,
that's a song bird.
You can't shoot them and eat them.
It's it's planet of the apes and it's
Cooper's people that don't have any
background whatsoever in wildlife for
hunting as well,
but that they're trained biologists.
That's different.
Right,
and they're influenced by politicians
and bureaucrats.
They're liars.
That question to wild boar,
like whenever I go to a restaurant it
says like wild boar sausage,
like how do you know it was a male?
Why are you calling it a boar wild pig?
It's.
It's a sound sexy Russian bores.
We have 8,000 Russian boards.
What are they,
gang?
They're out there in the woods.
Band each other.
Thank God.
Thank God they're all males there.
Maybe that's what happened.
Maybe they did have 8,000 boys and
they're all going,
where's the fucking check?
But how can the game department use that
kind of terminology?
Yeah,
it's a real problem with a straight
face.
It's a real problem.
Then when they,
when they speak about it that way,
you immediately dismiss what they're
saying because you're.
You're not.
They're not being accurate and not being
accurate with describing what the animal
is and you're inclined to dismiss
anything,
so you're only allowed to shoot those
sandhill cranes as a nuisance animal.
You can't shoot them and eat them.
It's unbelievable.
That's crazy.
And there,
by the way,
they're everywhere.
There's plenty of sandhill cranes in
Michigan to open the season in.
A lot of people go.
Have you ever talked to senators and
congressmen?
They go,
well,
you can't.
You can't shoot sandhill cranes.
I went,
it's a game bird.
He had dirt bag.
You need to cook it for him.
I watched the episode of Rinella show
and they were cooking.
I was like,
that looks like a steak.
It's time read animal.
Yes.
Red Meat.
You know,
it's just tragic in California.
Can Eat mountain lions.
You got to bury him.
He told me he didn't eat them.
If you shot one with the depredation
permit and the.
That's right.
Wow,
that's.
That's indecent in the animal.
That's why I'm confrontational.
I'm confronting indecency and trying to
get some honesty involved and you can't
do it by backing off and being Mitt
Romney like and bring a doily to a
grenade.
Fight.
Doily.
I like to bring an eight,
10 wart hog to a poker game.
Ted,
we just did three hours in like 15
minutes,
but I,
I'd even warmed up.
Just flew by right at this time.
Just flew by because it's a love fest of
truth,
logic and common sense.
Well listen,
man has been a pleasure to meet.
You should be able to sit down with you
again and have a good conversation here.
My friends were right.
You do deserve me and I think it's,
I think it's a good opportunity for
people to get a chance to see you in a
long form conversation rather than these
soundbites they could just choose to
hate,
especially when they sound bites her
edited and a manufacturer has it.
Let's make it perfectly clear.
I did not avoid the draft.
I did nothing.
Oh,
let's go to that.
I am raising real quick.
So that was an old school story of an
interview supposedly that you should all
over yourself and hype type.
By the way,
Joe,
you know me pretty well in the last
three hours.
If I had shit on myself to get out of
the draft,
do you think for a minute?
I would deny it.
No,
it was the stories out about.
I went in and got my draft physical and
by the way,
when I win in 1969,
I was superman.
I literally would hurdle Volkswagen
bugs.
I was all muscle and sinew.
I could.
I was superman.
I was the most athletic running,
jumping,
gazelle known demand,
and I went in for my.
I didn't know anything about Vietnam.
I didn't know anything about war.
My Dad was a war hero,
but nobody talked about it.
I never heard of the Bataan death march.
I graduated from the American education
system,
so I knew nothing and there was all
protests around me,
but I wasn't really tuned into the
protests because I was making music
every day.
I mean just obsessed with the amboy
dukes and playing gigs every day.
And I didn't pay attention.
I never watched a in my life,
but
I was given a draft notice and I went
down,
I went down,
I had my draft physical and I passed
with flying cover colors and I got a
draft card in the mail a couple of
months later,
uh,
through my mom and dad's house.
And one,
why not a deferment?
It's a designation.
I was in Oakland Community College at
the time,
so it was,
why was a student a designation?
I believe,
but I was ready to rock.
Um,
I didn't want to go.
I didn't understand me,
but my buddies were going,
uh,
John Break,
my singer had to go,
uh,
Rob Leonard from Amboy.
Dukes had to go,
uh,
so the only way you could have gone as
if you dropped out of school,
is that what it is?
No,
it wasn't a deferment.
I wouldn't,
I,
I would have been called anytime.
So you could have been called or just
weren't.
Sure.
And then the wikipedia claims,
I got a four,
f four f what is a four f four F emmys.
You're physically incapable.
I've never been physically incapable of
anything so they make this shit up.
So.
So I did an interview with high times,
which by the way,
let's make it clear.
I've done this so many times that people
ignore my actual statements.
So I had been doing interviews all
because the employee dukes were on fire
and I was just an outrage on stage with
the loin cloth and the bone Arrow and
feedback and he's killer songs and the
band was so good.
Greatest musicians in the world.
So I did interviews all the time talking
about the music I loved and they never
got anything right.
These stone dirt bag hippie writers get
the gas guys in the band's names wrong.
They got the facility wrong,
they mentioned songs we didn't perform,
they got nothing right.
And every time I'd read the interview,
God,
we're talking about my music.
You didn't even get the song titles
right.
So I started having fun with these
interviewers,
much to the entertainment of my band
mates who would break out in hysterics
when I'd make up stories because I'm not
going to even try to be accurate
anymore.
It was an ongoing maneuver of mine.
We'd have these hippie writers come in
to take notes and I'd say,
yeah,
I played his fender stratocaster as I
hold up my Gibson bird land,
which was known for.
And they'd write down,
he played in a Gibson a stratocaster.
There's no such thing as a guest.
So I was having fun with dirt bag anti
journalists.
So now I'm invited to high times
magazine and I was hardcore anti-drug.
So I go in and this guy is.
And
so,
uh,
so uh,
tell me about,
uh,
this I am boy,
do.
What?
Is it like a band?
I went,
yeah,
it's like a band.
So it's almost exactly like a bad fuck
kind of question.
Is this,
how did this get started?
Draft.
So anyhow,
we started talking about when I'm with
the MC five and the stooges and we
would.
And I go,
yeah man,
I was snorting something.
I don't know what it was,
man,
I just got higher than a kite.
And he goes,
wow,
you think it might've been a crystal
meth?
And I went,
yeah,
that's what they called it.
I never snorted,
just made up some shit.
Just went nuts.
And I,
we went into the war thing and I go,
I don't know anything about war.
I'm a,
I'm a guitar player.
But I went down for my draft physical
and when I went into the a booth to give
my urine sample,
I made sure I eat Mexican food all week.
So instead of pissing in the Urine Cup,
I took a big dump in it was green and
went all over the place.
And the guy went,
wow,
he really ain't really.
And so I made up the story for High
Times magazine,
you know,
the great magazine of good information.
And uh,
and then it turned out that my drummer,
Kj night,
God bless him,
he was actually admitted this in and
testified that that's what he did.
We thought it was the funniest thing in
the world were teenagers and this guy
went into the draft physical,
just an absolute near death lump of Shit
to get out of the draft.
And we thought it was funnier than hell.
We weren't paying attention to important
things in life.
And so the,
the Ted Hating liberal press started
quoting the high times magazine and
quoting an ex girlfriend who claimed
that I had adopted her,
that her,
I adopted my girlfriend to have you read
that one.
I did read that one.
I forgot about it.
So this kind of stuff,
I was like,
you adopted her so you could take her on
tour with,
you know,
so I could fuck her.
That's what the story was.
But that's APP.
Absolutely.
That's how it works.
That's not how I think.
It makes it easy to talk to them once
you adopt them.
I didn't adopt anybody Christ.
I never shit my pants since I was,
I think eight months old.
Um,
I've never been with an underage girl
since I was under age.
I'm not a racist.
And what else they said,
oh,
and they seem that they claim that I
made courtney love blow me when she was
12.
I think she claimed that.
Yeah,
I never met Courtney love.
You can tell I don't have a rash of you
gotta be kidding me.
They just make this shit up because they
know I'm so good at bringing my basic
conservative agenda forward that they
have to go full solid Linsky and lie and
lie and lie.
And if you go to Wikipedia to find out
about Ted Nugent,
they will repeat these lies.
They're lies.
And every one of those things,
every one of those things,
if I had done it,
I go,
yeah,
it was awesome.
But I didn't do any of those things.
Anyone can edit wikipedia,
you know,
very strange.
Think she might have edited it yet.
So it was,
I'm glad we got that.
So this thing is just persistent
forever.
Obviously it stuck in your crop because
you wanted to bring it up at the very
end.
It doesn't take up my cross.
Just.
It's a fascinating example of the
dishonesty and the anti journalism
agenda driven.
I'm anti Anti-american Anti-tech,
anti second amendment,
anti freedom buffoonery.
They exist.
I think it makes for an interesting
podcast exchange.
I think so.
It's not in my crotch.
It's not even in my universe,
but I notice it.
It's hysterical.
Ted nugent,
ladies.
Gentlemen,
there you have it fully.
Until next week.
Bye everybody.